foreign
good morning everyone we'll uh begin the
work session on House Bill 300.
prohibiting the disposal of certain food
waste
I do see uh Mike wimset here you know
I'll yield to the sponsor whether
there's someone that she'd like to call
on or
thank you very much uh Mr chair so there
are two folks here today that are
interested in speaking that I'm aware of
one is here to represent the New
Hampshire food bank and the other is to
represent Waste Management so I don't
know what your pleasure is who you'd
like to call first whoever you think
would be the most effective
they would be equally effective so um
have I
i o has another engagement he has to get
so for the division if you could just
state your name and I'm sure the prime
sponsor knows how to spell it so
for the record my name is Henry vayu and
I'm here on behalf of Waste Management
uh they operate uh one of the state's
largest uh landfill
in Rochester the turkey landfill
Steve pudgy who's the area director of
disposal operations I wanted to be here
this morning but he couldn't ask me to
come in his place
Steve serves on the solid waste working
group with representative Ebel and
they've been working for over a year
almost two years on the issues and food
waste has come up
um
and I think it was mentioned at the
hearing that EPA estimates that about 21
percent of Municipal Solid Waste
is food waste and the thing about food
waste is it it really doesn't need to go
in a landfill when we think about what
we want to put in landfills we want to
put things in landfills that really
there's no other use for it
and with food waste there are so many
other beneficial reuses for it
um
the thing about uh
diverting food waste though is that it's
kind of a chicken and an egg thing
um
the industry is hesitant uh to
create the facilities to manage food
waste without the demand
and without
facilities the demand won't be there so
it's kind of this chicken and egg and it
really takes something to happen to make
it all come together
and in Massachusetts
they passed a similar law requiring
large generators of food waste to divert
it from landfills
and waste management actually opened a
facility just outside of Boston it
processes 100 tons of food waste a day
and then they send it up to Lawrence
Mass
where it turns into energy
so that certainly is a beneficial reuse
of the material
um it didn't happen overnight even after
the law passed in Massachusetts it took
about two years
um for the facility uh to get full at
capacity so it's not going to happen
overnight
um and I think the approach The
Regulators took in Massachusetts was it
was more of a uh a reminding of the
large food waste generators that the law
had passed and that they should start to
think about and look at the Alternatives
and it also takes a little while for the
alternative facilities to
pop up so it's not something that's
going to occur overnight but it does
take that sort of trigger to get it
going uh and legislation like this
certainly would be that trigger that
could help a lot of again large food
waste gender and there are
in New Hampshire are some already uh
diverting the waste Dartmouth uh
uh Hospital up in um uh Lebanon is
already diverting theirs
um so uh I think the large generators
are in a in a good position to do it um
Hannaford uh which has operation New
Hampshire uh they're doing it up in
Maine
um so
um this is sort of a baby step taking
the large generators in Massachusetts
they reduced uh below one ton so they're
stepping it up a little more down there
but it does save space in landfills for
things that
that we don't have ideas for so that's
all I have to say
you take questions sure
Senator McGuire thank you do you know in
Massachusetts after this bill this past
what fraction of um the the input to the
landfills went down right so so how much
less was going into landfills I can find
that out and I'll get that to the
committee
further questions representative Weiler
thank you do you know if there's a plan
to build a composting plan in New
Hampshire by your company
if this uh passed the company certainly
would give it very serious consideration
they'd look at obviously there's got to
be the volume and it would probably be
and obviously Southern
New Hampshire uh where a facility I mean
you'd want Manchester Nashua uh you know
Seacoast uh
so
for other questions
represent evil
so
um I have spoke with Mr pogi quite a bit
and he is the regional director for
Waste Management which is basically all
of the Northeast and so I just want to
re-ask if you would reassert that just
as a planning mechanism for landfill
operators
you feel that you want to keep an eye on
preserving capacity for things that
really need to be landfilled as opposed
to food scraps and that you see this as
actually a business opportunity as well
yeah and we've already taken measures to
divert I mean yard waste yard waste is
already a Prohibition and I think that
used to represent 12 to 15 percent of
the waste and uh so that you know this
is sort of a The Next Step yeah yeah to
preserving for the materials as I said
yes represent kimberles
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question do you know if the like the
facility in Massachusetts is uh is it
profitable is it self-sustaining now
with what they're getting uh yeah it is
now self-sustaining as I said it took
about two years for that to happen
um which is interesting I mean a greater
Boston area you would think there'd be a
lot of food down there but it took some
time and it'll take some time up here in
New Hampshire but uh I think that's
where
things are headed you know the whole New
England area is starting to do this uh
so that company no longer requires
subsidies of any sort to maintain it's
itself uh well we never received any
subsidies it was a business decision and
um I think they saw that over time they
could eventually make it work and
representative evil and you said that
they're producing energy uh so it must
be an anaerobic yeah aerobic digester
yep great great I mean it's certainly
so I have a question so for your
Rochester facility
um how many tons are going in there
annually which you have that figure as
far as food waste and what capacity
Steve would know that it's like
you want to grab the mic sure
good morning uh Mike wimsat I service
director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire Des uh yeah
we our numbers are the last year that we
have
reported numbers for the turnkey
facility in Rochester it landfilled
approximately a million tons of uh of
waste in total if you just run you know
roughly we generally think about 20
percent of the MSW Municipal solid waste
that goes into a landfill is going to be
or food and organic waste so by that you
know calculation would be about 200 000
tons of the food that went of the waste
that went in there would be food waste
all right thanks Let's Help
represent McGuire has a question
but of this 200 000 you don't know what
fraction are from the people defined in
the bill namely more than a ton a day oh
is it a week today a week
and with with you know recyclers nearby
and all that sort of stuff absolutely
that that's correct we I'm not
suggesting that this bill would reduce
the waste going into TurnKey by 200 000
tons because it wouldn't it would be
some smaller portion of that we don't
really yet have numbers on what
portion of that of the total waste is is
from these large generators
um I suspect you know if you if you I
have a home compost pile sometimes it
feels like I bring a ton a week out to
that pile so it's hard to say but
um the raccoons like it so it's all
right but
um I guess uh it's it's definitely a
smaller number than that I would point
out Vermont has done a similar program
which they have phased into basically
it's now at a point where it's
essentially a ban on Pro a Prohibition
on landfilling all food waste so in in
Vermont they're they're you know to the
point where they've got homeowners
either participating in curbside
collection in some locations in the more
urban locations or they have
opportunities through the local transfer
station or other small composting
operations to to send their waste to
for the question thank you would this
Bill affect my local transfer station in
I mean maybe less waste I don't know no
I I I don't think it would in in the
first instance because you know the way
I think we would interpret it it's it's
the actual generator of the way so while
a transfer station may take in a ton of
food waste from its residents in any
given week it's not the generator of
that waste so I don't think it would
impact they don't have to sort or
anything no okay and one last question
what's the duties of the new employee in
this bill
oh um if if there were a new employee
basically what what when we filled out
the fiscal impact worksheet we what we
try to do is you know take a really
careful look and say if we're going to
do this you know full implementation the
rulemaking and a program to do Outreach
and education and then compliance
assistance and enforcement where
necessary we estimated it could take out
an FTE I think in practice
um what might likely happen is it would
be an initial push to do the rulemaking
to set up the program some Outreach but
then to be candid I think we would take
a a you know it's hard to imagine that
we would on an ongoing basis contribute
um a full FTE to this program I think
once it was up and running it wouldn't
take that much so if there were position
associated with this we we certainly
have we've just issued a solid waste
management plan in September we have a
number of implementation actions and and
plans and activities for the coming year
and then following that we believe that
employee would be engaged in many of
those those kinds of things
yeah so I would assume you're like most
and you have lots of unfilled positions
is that right uh no that that well it
depends on which part of the agency
right now
um the solid waste program
um has all of its positions filled
except for one
engineer position which still needs to
be filled and that's that's a difficult
position to recruit for because it's
hard to recruit engineers at present
um and then in the in the coming budget
there is an additional position that is
uh um in the governor's budget that
that's been submitted to the legislature
a lower level program assistant position
that would help with
um basically a collecting data and
managing data that we collect from from
from Solid Waste stakeholders so if if
we pass the governor's budget and this
bill do we have to add another position
or not
I I think that you know again we're
always very
um reluctant to say yeah we can just
take on anything you give us the reality
is we're we've we've got a full plate
right now and I'm I want to make sure
people know I'm not complaining we've
finally gotten the solid waste Bureau to
a point after many many years of being
under resource where we've got some
positions and we're really uh optimistic
about the things we're going to be able
to do moving forward to catch up with
our surrounding states having said that
new responsibilities like this really do
require that we have uh new new blood if
you will to help Implement them in the
in the the initial phase of these things
can be very time consuming because
you're really starting from scratch
you're trying to create a program that
we never administered before you've got
to do rule making and you've got to do
collection of data so you do that
rulemaking well and then you've got to
do the Outreach once you make the rules
to make sure people know what it is they
need to do to comply all right thank you
representative
um thank you so this is a little bit of
a segue but on the on the planning and
technical assistance
um wouldn't you say that even though you
finally have two people in your planning
and assistance and education program
with this new Solid Waste Management
plan to push forward you really could
use additional folks no question about
that absolutely thank you
any further questions
so I understand there's someone from the
New Hampshire food bank here okay if you
to come forward and state your name for
us and if it's difficult to spell
we'll start again Eileen loponis
executive director for the New Hampshire
Food Bank l-i-p-o-n-i-s
good morning
um I just wanted to let you know what
food Reclamation means to us and what we
participate in
um
we have very active
arrangements with all our grocery
partners and we Proclaim if they're
Salvage
we get it we pick it up but we also
enable our agencies and we have 400
agencies throughout the state so it
doesn't really make sense for me to send
a driver to
the Shahs and Colebrook I wish there was
one in Holbrook sorry
um up there and then back down so we
have our agencies that are local we
train them in food safety and then they
are able to pick up directly from the
grocery Partners so we are salvaging
that food waste throughout the state
with our grocery Partners already we
have a really great program with them
called Fresh rescue where they will
freeze the protein before it goes out of
date and that's the majority of the
protein that we use in our production
kitchen
we have a production kitchen that
produces approximately five to six
thousand meals a week they are at
aggregate Hotel pans that serve about 20
to 25.
we started composting last year in
February
in in all of 23 we did 10 and a half
tons of food waste
and you got to understand our our whole
place is Reclamation we never know
what's coming in the door the chefs go
downstairs every day see what looks good
our agencies that shop with us if you're
within 50 miles of the food bank can you
come and you place your order online you
have a date a time in 20 minutes to pick
up your order which is ready for you and
Shop the floor for anything extra that
comes in
um
it's a tremendous amount of food that we
are able to bring in from the grocery
Partners I can imagine that this would
be another source for us I do know of
other food banks throughout the country
that are able to benefit from this type
of in our industry it's called
institutional Salvage so that would be
your hospitals and your universities
the biggest portion of actual food
Reclamation that comes from those are
from your larger cities your Las Vegas
your Boston so I think in this instance
we're going to be looking for mostly
composting from our hospitals my sister
was a director of sustainability for
Seattle's children's hospital and she
said it for her it was very difficult on
the food safety and there's not enough
food safety regulations out there as far
as I'm concerned food safety is no hobby
we take it very seriously we train all
our agencies we train all our partners
it just takes one bad case of food
poisoning to bring an entire
organization and everything with it down
so we look to food safety in every
aspect of what we do but in Reclamation
it's very tricky as far as temperature
control goes so I'm sure there would be
food safety regulations that would be
followed along with this and we would be
happy for anything that could be
questions yes representative Sweeney all
right thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here to take questions from us
if you were to estimate could you give a
number on how much food that's usable
and safe that's currently in New
Hampshire going to landfills that your
organization could take advantage of
well the estimate is that
40 of everything that's grown produced
distributed is wasted
that's globally
in the United States I don't have that
number on me
um
we do the best we can
it's difficult
um food safety like I said is not a
hobby and we have to take it very
seriously
an estimate for the United States I'd
represent people
so I know I I recently participated in a
network Cafe for the food rescue
Alliance and there was a lot of
enthusiasm for having access to more
food um
don't you think in working with
additional uh larger generators of food
waste you could benefit by getting quite
a bit more food I mean assuming that you
comply with the safety regulations
um absolutely the hospitals will most
likely be the ones to have that type of
volume and there are recovery programs
that exist so that we would definitely
be looking to them
um to partner with but it would be under
all the food safety regulations that we
any further questions
oh okay I'll just that so I just want to
be clear you are in support of this bill
absolutely
all right seeing no further questions
thanks
representative me and japoodi I see you
waving at us you've got a few minutes
yeah
if you have time I could uh yeah quickly
this particular bill
um
my name is uh
representative manjipuri I represent
Hillsboro 11 from Nashua and I'm one of
the co-sponsors for this bill and I've
been very involved with a couple of
programs uh in terms of food waste and
there is a volunteer non-profit program
in Nashua called grow Nashua what they
do is just to give you some numbers and
what kind of waste is generated in
Nashua
um
there's about
250 tons a day
in Nashua that comes to the landfill
which is about 50 ton is Residential
Waste
and if you say 40 percent of 50 ton
is food waste
you do the math right about
40 time I mean about 25 to 30 tons of
you know at least 20 tons of food waste
per day that comes to the landfill so a
few years ago uh yeah gentlemen I don't
know if he has sent you the information
grow Nashua Justin Monroe started this
as a pilot
and if you go to the thing it's one of
the pictures that's my front door where
the J you know every Friday
there's a pickup they come with this we
have green buckets
to fill during the week put it out
Thursday morning I mean Thursday night
they pick it up and just by pre and I
pay like 25 30 a month
for this service because I don't have to
go to a place to dump my waste or save
it in my backyard which would be and
this is 335 days so all true and I can
say over three years
um from my bucket that comes I've done
more than a ton of waste
food waste and they pick up and he sent
uh pulls it together and compost and
they're not doing energy and he would
love to scale up and he has now three
full-time people that pick up
two trucks two and this is and there are
five houses out of 36 houses in my
neighborhood five houses that
participate in it just fine
and it's amazing how I fill up this one
so when I talk to the landfill folks
they said oh this would be a huge you
know Nashua has a landfill that has a
life for another 50 years but we are
filling up very quickly right and this
if we can do the compost expand the
compost and
also add the renewable energy that ways
to energy called the plasmogen pyrolysis
which you know not just food waste but
that's a whole different uh ball game
but I can tell you the way this has
scaled up non-profit is able to generate
enough you know donation as well as
employee people because
the program pays for itself for some of
the employees and it's been a wonderful
thing and I feel so proud to be able to
say you know what
I don't put up my trash barrel every
week maybe once a month between
Recycling and composting I barely put
out my big blue barrel for garbage so
that's I'm not contributing to the
landfill
so I would take a look and this is a
wonderful addition and I'm sure Mother
Earth will smile down on us and say
thank you
thank you for your testimony comments
any questions representative Weiler
your green bucket that you put out to
yeah because I see him tearing up
plastic bags it's not a bag it's a
barrel with a tight lid and so I put it
out at night because I forget to put in
the morning they you know but they come
and they let you know ahead of time I'm
glad it works thank you
I think representative Weiler has some
bears in his neighborhood like I do
as much as we say Nashua I have Bobcat
we have Fox we have bear
in Nashville too
representative evil I just wanted to
point out to the committee that uh grow
Nashua did send a letter for the
committee and I've distributed it to
everybody and there's also let uh
letters there from the Northeast
resource recycling Association that
works with a lot of municipalities in in
okay the division's pleasure with the
bill
so my question would be is this better
as a standalone bill by itself going on
to the senate or is it better as a
section of House Bill too
I would defer to the sponsor which her
the chair and thank you for the question
Mr Vice chair I think at this point
um it would be a great idea to retain
the bill within the committee
um
we're going to have uh the saw the waste
management division here again next week
with uh des and then we can talk about
it in its entirety okay I'll move to
retainment yes okay
it's been moved to retain by
representative McGuire seconded by
representative Hewitt would I get that
right
all right we'll just have a show of
hands I think that'll be easy enough on
this those wishing to retain
those opposed to unanimous
so we're right on time thanks guys
well I actually do have a minute or two
I said well
foreign
The Works session on House Bill 462
making an appropriation to the solid
waste management fund Etc representative
evil I believe wishes to speak
yes thank you Mr chair I mean I think um
I think a lot of the arguments in favor
of uh composting were made in the in the
last hearing this bill HB 462 is a bill
that would appropriate
two million dollars to the solid waste
management fund which the house
unanimously uh endorsed the passage of
last year but it remains unfunded
um
the
policy tweak that had it come through
Ena and then to us was that in the text
of the bill
because of the emphasis that the solid
waste working group felt should we
should have on compost and I think the
Des concurred we wanted to change the
language for the grant program to
emphasize in the first two years
composting so 50 percent of the funds
would be prioritized for food waste
diversion from um from landfills
um
what I just passed out was a letter that
I was asked by the solid waste working
group to send to the committee
supporting HB 300 HB 462 and then um
the ultimately the solid waste
management Bureau I have told you before
that the solid waste working group is a
is a stakeholder group what I did was I
gave you the working group member list
so you could see that it really
represents all walks of life
um I've talked to many folks about this
uh they're really excited from a
business standpoint and from um and
municipalities as you know the New
Hampshire
Municipal Association spoke in favor the
last time
municipalities have an ongoing struggle
with their solid waste and they really
are excited at the prospect of a grand
program like this so I hope we can vote
to retain it in the budget question
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative
um so how would this money be spent is
this to buy the green buckets to to give
out to people or something like that
um I
I can see that the uh that the director
is there I mean I I think that there's a
lot of flexibility built into the
language to try to help the businesses
and towns with their proposals
Michael
if I may sure Mike wimp said again
um what we envisioned for this program
and again I think the the members know
that the solid waste management fund was
created in the last legislative session
but it's yet to be capitalized in any
way so there's no no funding in the in
the fund
um if if funding were provided what we
envisioned would be and we have actually
a fair amount of experience with this in
other related programs we would put a
solicitation out for for Grant
applications and we expect that we would
get significant applications from
municipalities as well as from private
the private sector and the purpose of
the grant would basically be to
incentivize the development of alternate
business models and Technologies for
managing food and organic waste so it
could be you know someone who wants to
set up an anaerobic digestion uh process
on their Farm or it could be a transfer
station that would say well we we think
we could collect and compost food waste
from our residents since they're coming
here every Saturday anyways
um so it could be you know putting in a
concrete bunker or something for
receiving that and really it would be up
to the individual municipality or
private sector entity to to determine
what it is they would need but we would
anticipate it would be largely for
Capital Improvements necessary to uh
launch some kind of an effort to divert
waste from disposal
further question so does either this
bill or existing law
put limits or you know
so much per Grant fifty thousand is a
Max or something like that or I don't
believe there's a necessarily been a
total ceiling Max established but
they've been identified as matching
grants which and I'm trying to remember
I don't know that it actually specifies
50 but when we hear matching grains we
usually think they're 50 and and it
would depend it'd be competitive we have
uh I said we've done this in other
settings with using federal funds that
we've received for the brownfields
program we've done this for 15 years now
uh maybe 20 years we received those then
we put out a solicitation and in most
cases municipalities
um who have identified a property in
their in their community that is uh
where there are concerns about
contamination will apply for a grant
um to do site investigation to try to
position that
property for a cleanup so and to try to
encourage private investment in
purchasing cleanup the property and
restoring it to the tax rolls so we're
pretty good at administering that kind
of a solicitation and Grant the details
about you know what a ceiling would be
or what the match would be really have
not yet been worked out we would likely
do that through rulemaking
okay yeah just um do you expect to spend
this entire 2 million in this biennium
or is and and is this going to become an
ongoing request I I would say
um I would say if I were to try to
prognosticate I think it would be
unlikely we would spend that much in
grant funding in the biennium because I
think first of all it takes some time to
set up the program get solicitation out
and get the word out and then
um you know grants are terrific but they
don't make processes work of their own
accord we we would be looking at you
know as we uh as we looked at those
grain applications that we would get in
a competitive environment we'd be
looking for ones that had a business
plan and a structure that we thought
would be self-sustaining over time we're
not looking to be a you know a constant
subsidy to these programs we're really
looking to incentivize the development
of the development of them in the first
instance with the idea that the vision
that they would survive on their own on
their own accord and strength in the
future
representative Griffin
thank you Mr chair for
and thank you for taking the question
um I see that it got amended this this
bill got amended by the house and it it
gives you basically your your division
uh the authorities solicit funds from
any Source you know donations grants Etc
I know that the budget is really tight
we've finally got some Revenue figures
so I don't know whether it's likely that
you're going to get two million dollars
this year but I wonder what is the
likelihood of you being able to solicit
funds from another source
uh it's hard to say I think that there
are opportunities out there we were
actually hopeful when the fund was first
created that we would be able to go
after what we knew would be EPA grant
funding that was going to be targeted
towards Solid Waste for as part of the
bipartisan infrastructure law indeed
that funding has been appropriated and
we are likely to get a grant that will
help us to do a number of things related
to planning and Outreach but
unfortunately despite our efforts uh
significant efforts to try to convince
EPA otherwise they didn't get
comfortable with the idea of States
getting the scrant money and then using
it to make sub grants to municipalities
or businesses so we're we're still
engaged in that debate with them and
we're in their program is evolutionary I
guess I would say this they've never
made they've never had funding for solid
waste before so I I'm as part as a New
Hampshire representative in my
counterparts in the New England states
in the northeast states have been
talking with EPA about that and we're
hoping that in future years they will
kind of see that this could be a a
productive way to use their funds but to
date we don't have the authority to do
that
someone a follow-up to representative
Griffin's question I see by the fiscal
note that about a half a million a
little more than a half a million would
be appropriate for 26 and 27 so maybe if
we get the program off we wouldn't have
to go for the entire 2 million but
something less than that for the at
least this this biennium without going
to the next biennium I think that's
where
representative Griffin was probably
headed
all right anything else Sir Michael
see no other questions thanks Mike the
kid
representative McGuire so uh this seems
similar to the previous bill so maybe we
should move to retain it as well
representative McGuire is moving to
retain is your second second by
representative Griffin
we'll just have a show of hands they'll
make it easier for our clerk everyone in
favor of doing that
those opposed it's unanimous thanks
for the house it's not new like some of
them have been coming to us like the uh
docket how the vote went down was it
non-recommendation or did it pass
unanimously and if there was a house
so Mike carries a docket with him so we
can get a pretty good idea
how this is coming to us so we're
looking at house bill 230.
that came out of the executive
departments and administration committee
with a
ought to pass vote of 18 to nothing
all right thank you
so very quickly representative Bixby
would you like to
so
thirty thousand what view of this
and so we know we sure we're already
here that we've met once on it so we
have a pretty good idea we met spoke to
the Commissioner of Agriculture it was
obviously supportive
so um last time I sort of talked about
how I came to put this in at this point
I just want to talk about the
ramifications So currently in the
Department of Agriculture markets and
Foods
nothing is automated uh there is uh so
everything that gets submitted to the
department has to be uh entered uh the
the data entry is still by hand using
basically 1980s technology
it will save you a lot of testimony
because that's what we heard from the
commissioner when he was here to speak
to it so okay explain it was I guess
someone involved that was actually
incarcerated that came up with a plan
initially and that person is no longer
around and that was quite an interesting
story right so um I just want to point
out that this is this is basically every
single
operation that the department does that
is using
way outdated technology and it is
fundamentally a waste of Department
resources to have skilled people doing
data entry when they could be actually
doing the things that are they're
supposed to be doing under statute like
assessing uh the uh assessing fertilizer
um
composition like making sure that
pesticides are being applied
appropriately one of the things with
pesticides is that the reporting for
pesticide use is now annual so a
pesticide company will keep a list of
what they have been spraying for a year
and then send that in that's not really
useful it was useful if there's an issue
with spray drift you want to be able to
track that pretty quickly so if they
were able to if the pesticide
applicators were able to
submit what they had sprayed
immediately after they sprayed it which
would probably be more convenient for
the applicators too then that would give
us a essentially an up-to-date current
set of data in case there's a issue that
needs to be tracked down this same
problem can be sort of
there are analogous issues with every
single licensing and Reporting uh part
of the the activity that goes on in the
department including weights in my
including weights and measures which is
basically making sure that consumers are
getting a fair uh you know the the what
what they're buying is actually reported
fairly so um with that I'll I'll take
any questions
seeing none I believe oh I'll ask so it
I'm I'm in favor of improving technology
Etc the main thing about this one is the
the ongoing costs feels very high 200
000 a year of Maintenance that's like
two people right so yes and but if you
consider that currently
most of the employees in the department
are doing that work if you
uh then you are getting an immense
savings by reducing it to the cost of
effectively two people the other thing
is that uh that the registration and
Licensing fees that the department
brings in
will be sufficient to cover that ongoing
cost uh so it's just a matter of doing
getting over the initial hump of getting
it set up and when the commissioner said
that he wanted to ask for 360
000 I thought wow that's cheap so
further questions so so next time we'll
you'll have to talk and talk to the
commissioner about that one all right so
I'll move to retain I think this is a
worthwhile thing and we need to put it
in the budget thank you
okay it's been moved by representative
McGuire's second by representative
Griffin okay I thought I heard something
over there
um all right now just a show of hands I
believe should be sufficient those favor
those opposed all right we'll retain
this and try to find a place for it in
I see something that should an item that
shouldn't take too much time uh
hopefully house built 347 the
establishing of a superior court land
and would just get a little history from
Mr Hoffman
this bill came out of the Judiciary
Committee
ought to pass with Amendment
of
a vote of 16 to 4.
and it was adopted on the floor by Voice
all right thank you representative Lynn
uh thank you Mr chairman I uh come
before you in support of of the bill I
um I did have should note I did have
some discussion with uh representative
McGuire who suggested that
um the the appropriate way to handle
this since the Judiciary in its budget
has included the judge position uh you
know that would that would Encompass the
land use Docket in its budget that the
appropriate way for this committee if
you're so inclined to handle this would
be to retain the bill and put the uh and
put the language of of HB 347 into the
into hb2 and then include the the money
in the budget so that that makes perfect
sense to me
um
um I'm happy to answer any questions
anyone may have
signal questions I'll accept emotion
from representative Griffin I think Mr
thank you Mr chair I moved to retain the
bill
um Second and it's second is its
discussion representative McGuire so
um thank you representative Lynn
um the one sentence so essentially we
would be copying part one of your bill
into House Bill 2 but the one sentence I
would think of removing is
um on line 30 of page
uh
I don't see any page one I guess
um
yeah right well it's just that the third
um nothing in this section shall affect
current jurisdiction of the housing
appeals board so
um I'm personally thinking about that we
should
um remove the housing appeals board
because they haven't been used very much
um as a as a way to save some money so
I'm wondering if I took out that
sentence and and force those things into
this well I guess what I I mean to be
completely candid with you that that was
an amendment that was put in at the
suggestion of the ranking member of the
Judiciary Committee of Representative
Smith
um who felt very strongly that
um
that the housing appeals board was
important and that it should remain in
effect
um and candidly I you know my my sense
was that even if that language hadn't
been in there that that nothing in this
bill would remove the housing appeals
board nothing in the bill itself
um
and I guess what I would what I would
say is is this I I know that different
people have different feelings on the
housing appeals board
um it act the the issue of the housing
appeals board I should say actually
became an issue in my campaign for
re-election and which caused me
to you know to really sort of delve into
because that the the housing appeals
board was was adopted before I ever
before I was ever elected to the
legislature so it actually caused me to
to say you know I really ought to look
at this
um and so I read at what was at that
time you know in October or November of
of 2022 every decision that had been
rendered by the housing appeals board
because it had been claims made that
well you know this this board is just
designed to be sort of a pass-through
for developers they're reversing every
decision of local planning and planning
boards and I have to say my sense of
have from having read every decision was
that they really weren't you know making
off-the-wall decisions my I did a fair
amount of of these kind of appeals when
I was a superior court judge and earned
a few and quite a number on appeal when
I was on the Supreme Court and my sense
was as a general matter
that the housing appeals board came to
the same decision that a superior court
judge would have come to effect you know
maybe taking a a bit long a fair amount
of time longer but that their decisions
were not off the wall uh in any sense so
I'm not trying to imply that at all so
what we are concerned with on this
committee and your former member is
value for money and the bear facts are
that the housing appeals board in two
years handled 65 cases
and judge NATO said to us this judge
will handle 200 such cases in one year
and in half time and the other half time
will be doing standard Superior Court
cases you see what I mean no no I do I
do too I know I do I do assume you I
mean I guess all I wanted I just wanted
to further for for the benefit of
members of the committee I just wanted
you to understand sort of the history of
this I
I am certainly in favor of whatever
system will provide the most efficient
way to handle these cases in the you
know in the in the least amount of time
and if that if if this committee
believes that that the way to do that is
to just have the Superior Court land you
stock it
um that you know that that's fine with
me
representative Weiler
that's that is a a policy move
which we try to avoid right
um and before we make such a move
we have some things like performance
audits
and we could request performance audit
and have them contrast the two systems
and and bring us back the sort of data
that that uh
representative Lynn mentioned to see
what's the efficiency and what are we
getting and how much is it costing in
each and that would be a good thing
before we'd make such a a move because I
remember we talked about it for a couple
years before we brought in the housing
appeals board and there was a lot of
support for it and so it if if you uh
just summarily dismiss it at this point
as a financial situation you'd be in a
big trouble I think so it's better it's
better to deal with the policy situation
and at least if we're going to make any
move to eliminate something have some
real data that we can look at and say it
costs so much to do the court the thing
here and so many delays and here's
here's what happened in the court and if
it turns out that the rumors we were
told it took three years to get to court
and they did it in six months because
they have a requirement to do that in a
short time so those are things we need
to look at before we make such a
precipitous move thank you you know if I
could just make one just maybe make one
of the one other comment on this is they
um you know my my sort of expectation
um and obviously this committee has to
do what you think is right but my
expectation had been that that what
would make the most sense would be
to to leave the two track system in
effect for you know two or three years
see how things sort of work out and then
if it if the if the land use appeals
board works out as I think it will you
know a very efficient way to handle
these things then it might at that point
it might make sense to eliminate the the
hab and I guess the the one thing I
would say is you know to the extent that
you you point out and I I can't disagree
with you on the question of of
efficiency
um we we have had four geez as long as I
can remember at least 50 years I think
we have had the sort of two-track system
with regard to the board of tax and land
appeals and the superior court and you
know at least as far as I know nobody
has sort of been complaining about that
saying that it's inefficient to do that
and and whatever so you know me my
impression is that what happens in that
what has developed over the years and
that is that
the simpler cases tend to for of tax and
land you know uh tax assessment uh
complaints or eminent domain the simpler
cases tend to go to the board of tax and
land appeals and the really big cases
involving let's say utility taxation or
whatever go to the superior court maybe
it would turn out you know two or three
years from now if you had both the land
you stock it and the housing appeals
board that that same thing would kind of
develop there I don't know but that's
that might be one reason to sort of you
know Let it Fly with the two two track
no I am a little sympathetic to
representative McGuire's concern as I
recall the housing appeals board had a
budget of just shy of six hundred
thousand dollars and if you look at the
superior court judge position it was
significantly less than that so I think
that's from a financial standpoint I can
see where representative McGuire was
coming from
yeah I think they're quite similar
actually they're both in the 500 plus
range but again one was doing a lot more
cases than the other now that you're
right that the board of tax and land
appeals is a completely different story
because that one is stressed you know
they they have they're got more cases
than they can handle almost and so that
one we we if we had a funds we would add
to maybe add a person to because they
they are very popular and heavily used
and all that sort of stuff so the two
situations are not necessarily
comparable
all right all right there's been a
motion to uh
all this and uh
to put in the budget is that what I
understand correctly okay well part one
part one with a possible Amendment from
you I guess
all right seeing no more discussion
those in favor of retaining this bill
those opposed it's unanimous
so we'll back up on our list and go to
House Bill 337 relative
to direct the office of professional
licensure and certification to provide
a good representative from a Hudson
how are you
what's that
no I guess not
thank you
um for the record my name is Joe nullery
I'm co-sponsor of House Bill 337 I
represent the town of Hudson now
ah first I'm going to read a note from
uh representative Merchant who is the
sponsor of the Bill of prime sponsor in
my opinion the fiscal note remains above
what I believe is necessary note that
the expense would come from the oplc
operating revenues that is licensing
fees and permits not from the general
funds that is taxes another bill is
working its way through Ways and Means
which would create a non-lapsing fund
for the oplc that would allow the agency
to retain somewhere around five million
dollars to smooth out cash flows between
all the boards so 90 000 per year should
be have little to no impact on the oplc
budget uh I was just getting some
schooling on the fiscal notes that was
provided by the LBA and it appears that
it sits off a little bit because
if you take a look at the classified
employees a uh pay scale for a grade 28
step one it's 94 000 a year two times
that is 188
000 and then 112 for the other employees
however that's not the purpose of the
bill
it's unfortunate
but as you read the bill
doesn't talk about expending a lot of
money it talks about
conforming to existing law
I was part of a commission this summer I
was a bipartisan commission served with
the
representing Merchant and and several
others regarding uh the oplc and its
restructuring
one of the things that was strongly
pushed was a lack of communication a
lack of notice meetings were being held
the purpose of this bill is to
make it crystal clear
that RSA 91a public meetings applies to
oplc and the commissions of which it
oversees
that's the key position
as for the funding we do have the uh
um non-lapsing fund that will be
established which should cover the most
the cost oplc says even in the fiscal
note here that it should be able to
cover the cost of this in-house at the
current time
there's a representative from oplc here
today and there's a representative from
oh
regarding the operation of the uh oplc
when it's restructured this should be
able to fit right within their General
operating it should not be an additional
expense either to the regulated entities
or to the taxpayers of the State of New
Hampshire so
you know the policy of making sure that
91a is complied with has already been
agreed to the only thing sticking here
is whether or not
it's going to cost money and it's my
opinion it's representing Merchant's
opinion that it's not going to cost any
additional money but will benefit the
state
by making sure that
meetings are public and that oplc when
we get the our reorganization done we'll
be able to operate this in an effective
manner uh
we're already mostly through this budget
year so
well we'll let it go at that and I'll be
happy to answer any questions I can to
my limited expertise but I would defer
specific questions regarding the
operation of oplc to jeez oplc
before we move any further my apologies
Mr Hoffman I didn't ask you to let us
know how this proceeded from the
committee to the house and the votes and
this uh this bill came out of the Edna
committee
with an ought to pass
ought to pass with amendment by a vote
of 20 to zero
and it passed the floor with a past the
house with a Voice vote we do have a
revised fiscal note dated
um February 28th
yeah everybody should have that in their
packet
um
the original fiscal note
showed roughly uh 311 dollar impact on
General and other funds and
this one shows a general and other
impact of around 94 to 99 thousand
dollars
you know up two and yeah up two up two
is like yeah
are there questions representative
Weiler
thank you Mr chair representative ulery
we have about a hundred and
127 pages in hb2 all dealing with oplc
do you imagine that this study committee
Iran had something to do with that
I imagine a lot of things
ah and it is very possible that that
study committee uh had some input onto
that there were uh some entities that uh
we need to license in the state there's
no question about it uh there are other
entities such as braiding hair that
doesn't necessarily need to be
regulated with a license
maybe business certification is enough
thank you
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move out to pass on
the house bill 337
um and speak to my motion if you get a
you may discuss all right so I spoke to
representative Carol McGuire about this
bill and apparently the reason for the
large initial
um fiscal note had to do with a
error in the drafting of the bill like
an L was a one or something and and
so it really isn't a bill that that has
a lot of money in it it's it's all
self-contained within oplc
um both both the bill that
representative ulrey is talking about
and also House Bill 2
makes oplc essentially controlled all by
other funds and so therefore there's
this is there's no General funds in this
bill so
so you saying the fiscal note is
incorrect because it does check off
General funds
well the fiscal note has to be based on
current law not based on prospective
future law right and so when if and when
as we expect lplc will be sort of become
a separate entity and and
have their own kind of fund then that
won't be general fund take it out of
your wallet yes okay so representative
evil has a question yeah so I take it
this is not included in the overhaul of
it's really a separate policy thing
about notifications right it's not a
changing any licenses or yeah
okay so the motion has been made by
representative McGuire seconded by
representative Kimbrell's
but Sweeney
oh
yeah okay
no that's yeah
all right
so we're all clear it's a motion of
ought to pass
well actually because it's a motion to
move something to the full committee
will take a roll call when the clerk is
ready
my first exciting moment
this magic
so um
representative Maguire yes
let me just say that we're voting on HB
337 and the motion is ought to pass
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrows yes
um the clerk votes yes
okay uh representative Hewitt yes
and representative actually
representative walner
I called McGuire okay
all right and the chair and represent
that chair representative Weiler yes
you're not on this list for some reason
and representative yes
okay
nine zero
voting 9-0
the bill passes will be referred to the
so the last one at 10 30 we if we go
time to if if is the head of oplc here
no
I I have a question for oplc
and if you could state your name Douglas
general counsel for oplc o s t e r h o u
d t pronounced exactly as it's spelled
except for the silent letters
I need a new joke I use that everywhere
it doesn't get the lapse anymore
thank you for being here I'm looking
through hb2 but I didn't see
whether this hit a fiscal note for all
this reorganization for for hp2 I
haven't had an opportunity to review hb2
yet so I am not the expert on that it
came out yesterday morning I have been
working on at the request of the Edna
subcommittee on 655 amended a language
to 655 that I submitted this morning hp2
is my weekend homework assignment so all
right so if you would ask the agency to
have by net early next week absolutely
what the uh
fiscal effects are of all this
reorganization so if the fiscal effects
are similar to 655 take this with a
grain of salt and I will confirm this
and get back to the committee next week
then it should be uh
it's basically just moving
current law into six five five and
certainly also you you eliminated some
some certifications and some licensing
so I don't know how many maybe six seven
didn't read like that many 34. so there
should be some savings that would also
be of great interest to us
absolutely thank you
I just so everyone knows I've referred
the entire section dealing with these
changes to Edna since there's some major
policy changes get their read before we
Act
thank you and I I actually did attend on
Tuesday the Edna committee meeting and
oplc will be probably at every single
meeting
representative McGuire you must have a
question not a question but we did get a
piece of paper from the LBA on on the
fiscal changes of eliminating those
licenses right it was 900 000 a year or
something like that I saw a piece of
paper no
well you are right there is a
significant uh decline in Revenue
because of those fees right because
there was there was like eight licenses
eliminated and
you know like lnas normally brings in
150 000 and some other you know there
was some other numbers there do you
remember no
okay I'm not sure if that's something we
produce because neither one of us
recalls it okay I think it was presented
by oplc there was a pretty sharp decline
in some Revenue but they thought they
might make it up because more people may
take advantage of the shared Cooperative
license sharing or something but it was
something I think it was in their budget
presentation on the last page it had the
reduction of the 900 plus thousand
dollars based on the licensing you're
correct
so next we have uh House Bill 576
relative to the administration of a
commercial property assessment or says
clean energy sea pace
I believe we have an amendment is that
let's see and if we could get that
I think this is very helpful that the
yes this uh this bill came out of the
science technology and energy committee
with the report of ought to pass with
um
the uh
results of the house floor was a Voice
vote to adopt that Amendment
so representative from Nashville I
believe you were working with
representative Sweeney and someone from
the banking community and you
have an amendment that you'd like us to
consider
correct and uh thank you to I apologize
the last time you had it was a total
confusion in my hand and I didn't show
up for the work session and I appreciate
a second opportunity to come before you
and uh representative Sweeney has the
Incorporated the banking
Bankers request so let me just go over
um
2023-1-0162 H you should all have that
that replaces the original bill in
entirety which was five HP 576.
uh and including the title
where in the original bill it said
establishing Reserve fund
and so this amendment replaced and just
included to make it an enabling
legislation
and what the enabling legislation
is to the first of all the
title is changed to relative to
administration of a commercial property
assessed clean energy
the keyword is the commercial program in
a Clean Energy Efficiency and clean
energy District so the word funding
fund is not even there so that's a huge
step
and
in that
Paces property assessed clean energy
which means any assessment of the
property value because of the
Improvement of the clean energy like the
conservation efficiency is
based on
the property and it stays with the
property
just like the mortgage the property
value stays with the property and the
borrower can change
without the C pace
the
if I make an improvement in my
multi-family apartment complex
getting the loan
and
that is on top of the mortgage so the
lien is not on the property so the
investor clean energy investor seepace
investor will not get if there is a
default
okay so mortgage lender
will have the first the municipalities
of course the property tax taxes and
then the in a mortgage lender so the in
what is
C Pace I don't know if how detailed you
want me to go into so you can clarify or
I can clarify or stop me when I don't
have to
you could probably stop there if you
comfortable okay
so the only changes
that the amendment that uh
representative Sweeney brought in
the amendment that passed on Voice vote
and uh this committee
right two and five is where the it was
struck
and
which was the mortgage the this
ought to say 80 will include except that
all prior recorded mortgages or liens
shall retain property over the lien of
the assessment contract unless all set
mortgages or lien holders of record have
consented to the lien as provided by RSA
53 f
5 so this is if there is already a lien
and already a mortgage holder they if
they give consent to the new
improvements in the loan
it can be added as a equal if it is not
then the C pays investors not the
investment is not in part to the market
foreign
representative Sweeney thanks for
working this out and further comment on
it yes thank you I just want for the
record to state so after our work
session uh the next day while we had
session during a break uh myself the
representative from the bankers
Association and chairman Bose from the
science technology and energy committee
that first had this the focus on the
policy uh he reiterated that he was one
in support of the underlying policy that
turned it into enabling legislation uh
and then as we began to discuss the
banking implications of the bill he
actually stopped us in our conversation
and said we talked as a committee to
sort of let the next committee tackle
the banking issue that was in the bill
so I took the suggested amendment that
the bankers presented to US during the
work session brought that to OLS and
that's the uh zero six nine two H uh
that I passed around I also had Janet
Prentice
this should be right underneath a binder
for you and then um the municipal
Association shared with me this uh
document from the sea Pace Alliance
which is the National Group in support
of C Pace loans about the mortgage
lender's guide and I just had Janet
print copies and I passed those around I
don't know if those made it around the
table uh just kind of gives the overview
just of how even the C Pace wants the
mortgage process to work
um my understanding and I had the
bankers review the proposed amendment
they are
from my understanding their support of
the proposed amendment to fix the issue
with the lien holders and the priority
loans so that's that's what I can report
based on the work so
thank you representative Sweeney
so see no more questions on the
amendment
representative Griffin well it's really
not a question I'd like to say that I
was against this bill
originally
but all my concerns are addressed by the
amendment and I think I think it's good
work and we need to go with it okay
again thanks for your efforts
representative Sweeney well done
so we'll just have a show of hands to
20230692h I'll show our hands
so unanimous
so when the clerk is ready I'll ask for
a motion to accept
the bill is amended
that's uh I'll spill five seven six yes
so does this have any budget impact if
it's indeterminable
yeah
so explain maybe someone should explain
in what way it might have a budget
impact yeah
um if I can take a shot at it yes
because this is a savings conservation
efficiency right it's prevention so how
do you put a cost to the prevention
right now we have no space uh C based
investors in the state because there's
no enabling legislation to come and
invest in it so
is there a cost to the state or the
municipality no
it is the private property owners
non-profit
whoever so
um from that
there's nothing coming out of the state
budget
yeah we have the
the latest fiscal note dated 228 which I
think is no change for the initial
fiscal note Mr Hoffman that came with
the bill
it it actually did change from the
initial fiscal note okay and this is a
situation where
um
we went back and forth in writing this
we if the bill had been introduced in
its present form we may have not even
had a physical note at all
because it's something that communities
can choose to do it doesn't Force
anything
so to just to go back to that I had the
original bill and I brought the
amendment to my initial uh public
hearing and it was not accepted at that
time so the amendment was not accepted
at the initial uh you know and uh all
the discussion was based on the bill
that was not in existence so that's why
in the work session are not the exact
session I had to bring not I couldn't
bring a Amendment but one of the
committee members had to bring an
amendment and I had to be there to say
this is what it is and I couldn't
incorporate the bankers representative
Sweeney thank you just based on the
really light research I did this does
the way it is now after the Amendments
uh it is enabling legislation to the
municipalities and the Sea PACE program
is really designed for municipalities
with 50 000 residents or larger uh which
we have too in New Hampshire so it is
for just those municipalities so those
municipalities if they choose locally to
pursue this enabling legislation uh
that's where any taxpayer cost would
come but that's on there that's on them
representative Griffin
representative Griffin seconds
and that's um
house bills
576 with Amendment zero six nine two H
right
yes okay calling the role representative
McGuire yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrose yes
yes representative Hewitt yes
clerk votes yes representative Wyler yes
and representative leishman yes
okay the vote is unanimous at nine two
House Bill 330 FN relative to the
National Guard recruiting incentive
program and it's funding in rule making
is this hasn't been to the floor right
yet or did it come out of the DNA yeah
Edna it's new to us we haven't heard it
yet
so Mr Hoffman what do we have on the
it's going to take me a minute to get
the docket because I didn't have that
come on
so this bill came out of the state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
ought to pass vote of 13-0 and it had a
um yeah it doesn't tell me whether it
sorry
yeah
anyway uh here we are Mr Hoffman the
I was looking at the wrong laptop there
it
it came out of a military Affairs and
Veterans Services unanimously 13-0 and
then passed for The Voice vote on the
floor
all right
let's hear it welcome and if you could
state your name for the record please
and I forget your last name if you could
um for the record my name is Aaron zayak
it's Z as in zebra a y
a c as in Charlie
correct yes
I am um the administrator of business
um so basically
um this bill really just has three
components
um the first component of it raises
enlistment incentive payments
um and those incentive payments are
meant for current and former members of
the New Hampshire National Guard
um so it'll bring that up from 500 to a
thousand
um the second piece is it um it removes
rule making requirements for both the
post-secondary education assistance and
enlistment incentive programs So within
our statutes under 110 um B colon 8A we
are exempt from rule making so this just
really administratively cleans up
um cleans up our statutes and finally it
allows us it kind of gives us a place to
take fines collected through military
Justice process
um and and gives us a spot to to kind of
Park those so we'll be putting those or
cutting those into the enlistment
incentive
thank you any questions represent
camberells thank you Mr chair uh you
just when you you gave your introduction
you said the incentive is for current
and former uh can you explain former or
what how that would work
yes so it's actually
um we have internal processes that have
been developed to determine so basically
we'll work in conjunction with our
military Partners our federal Partners
to determine
um the person coming forward whether or
not they were a former member and the
status of that former member before we
make payments so they'll um both Army
and air have kind of their processes to
vet the person
um once that's once that's vetted it
will come through the state business
representative uh yes Weiler
thank you I haven't been involved in
this some time ago this is a competitive
market we have former military people or
people that are looking to to join the
military
and they have a choice in the National
Guard they could go to Massachusetts
Maine Vermont to any nearby State and
they all always look at the incentives
one of the incentives we've always given
is is a a tuition break at State schools
which
I remember at one point Massachusetts
would give you the full four years in
one of the colleges we we kind of
it was space available type thing I
don't know if it still is but
so we have to stay competitive to get
the enlistments we need thank you
now uh represent a former representative
baldazzaro was very keen on some of this
stuff do you still have the education
benefit to help people with secondary
education and
yes and I don't know off the top of my
head the exact details but we still do
have education benefits and we certainly
continue to pursue other options or
continuing to expand those
um so again as data by representative
Weiler we we do try to maintain um being
very competitive New England is a small
area so it's easy for someone within New
England to kind of choose which guard
they want to be a part of so we want to
really try to keep them in New Hampshire
where possible representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here Tara question this is I'm
going to start with an assumption and
you can correct me if I'm I'm wrong but
it would appear the last three years for
the guard where some of the busiest
years for the National Guard and if that
impacted retention and recruitment
whatsoever
yes we were we were extremely busy
um but I I will say just um based on
daily operation brief that we get and
this is dated 2nd of March
um our we're still under are authorized
Manning not by a ton but on the um on
the New Hampshire Army National guys
guard side we are still falling about
160 slots below our authorized Manning
so we're not we're not getting there
just yet
I was going to recognize representative
while or maybe for a motion you're going
to have a lot of writing to do at some
point but
representative representative Weiler
moves ought to pass
is a representative cambrell's second
signal further discussion when the clerk
is ready you please call the roll on 3
30. all right odd to pass okay
um
I have to pass motion
motion for 330 representative McGuire
yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative
yes
Wallner
representative Hewitt yes clerk votes
yes and representative Wyler
yes
and representative leishman yes
uh the HB 330 motion ought to pass uh
so we're just about right on time but
only knows what I need
what's that I said he said you need two
so openly work session on House Bill 379
requiring notice to provide tenants
during
residential eviction proceedings
representative Reed I'm assuming you're
thank you and thank you honorable
members yes
um as was the comments that I just heard
you all speak about
um the bill has no fiscal impact at all
in its current form as amended and
supported unanimously out of the
Judiciary Committee
it simply says that the contact
information for legal assistance will be
included in any eviction notice doesn't
increase the number of eviction notices
or anything like that so no uh no impact
on printing or anything even that minor
so it had started as a bill creating an
empty bucket because I've had a number
of uh of meetings with Senator Maggie
Hassan's team and they are indicating
favorably that perhaps we may be able to
get funding for a tenant eviction lawyer
fund so that's how it started but that's
not the form in front of you and not the
form that passed unanimously out of
Judiciary so
um yeah kind of shouldn't be here but
there you go Mr Hoffman docket
oh Melissa thanks uh so I went to
Judiciary Committee
committee with an ought to pass with
Amendment recommendation uh 20-0 and
then I went to the house floor and
passed this floor with the ought to pass
Amendment on a Voice vote
thank you
yeah so I mean the the only possible
objection to this bill is you know the
judicial council is like a 44 million
dollar a year operation and this is
essentially advertising to get the more
business so you know it could cost money
in that way but you know obviously we
I'll make it not to pass motion I don't
that was safe no yeah so the
has been made of ought to pass was moved
by representative McGuire seconded by
representative Griffin when the clerk is
ready please call the roll on art to
pass
all right on the ought to pass motion
for HB 379 representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambros yes
representative Wallner
representative Hewitt yes clerk votes I
representative Wyler yes
and representative leishman yes thank
you very much representative Reed
so we're adjourned until one o'clock
okay
foreign
so we'll open the work session on 5 34.
this is new to us we haven't had a work
session on this one before uh Records
almost fully representative Hoffman is
getting that light way I guess but yeah
if you just give us a docket history
please
so this bill uh came out of the
resources Recreation and development
committee with an 11-9 vote vote to pass
the Minority Report was in expedient 11
legislate
all right is someone here that would
like to speak to 534
thank you for the for the record I'm uh
Bob Scott I'm commissioner with the
Department of Environmental Services uh
representative Boyd asked me to attend
uh so for this program
uh I can go in as little or as as much
as you want to it's an existing program
that the agency is running again for the
drinking water groundwater trust fund uh
we are we are responsible for
administering those funds so the trust
fund set up three years ago this program
uh to look at uh providing well
assistance again more than 50 roughly 50
of the well uh water uh private water is
being served through Wells rather than
water systems and uh the context of this
uh is for natural disasters so of late
the past three years uh different parts
of the state have been in severe drought
uh we will see what happens tomorrow
that will be a help towards that
alleviating that that end or tonight
rather
um but even with that uh it really is an
issue for Drought for New Hampshire with
how much uh recharging if you will of
the aquifers so there's I give it a 50
50 chance that uh you know after June
this year we'll be back into a drought I
hope I'm wrong so that was really where
this program has been focusing of late
the concept though is not just for
droughts so a good example is some years
back prior to covet if any of us can
remember that we had severe storms uh
that included some flooding around the
baker River and the scouring that was
associated with that changed the water
table for nearby Wells in uh I want to
say Warner I keep the name Warren New
Hampshire uh so that was kind of the
opposite but it resulted in permanent
loss of water for some private Wells at
the time uh Senator uh gaida did a fun
GoFundMe page because there was no other
way to fund this type of thing to help
those folks so that was kind of the that
type of event was kind of the emphasis
for this since then the drinking water
groundwater trust fund has allocated a
little over 3.1 million dollars towards
this effort we've helped uh roughly well
not roughly we've helped 160 private
well owners either have their Wells uh
modified or to actually connect to
public water I believe uh for the trust
fund the intent of this legislation
again we've been asked to provide
support for it was to kind of codify
and make this a long-term thing this has
been happening for the trust fund I
think the desire was to we're seeing the
need the understanding was and again
representative Boyd is the current chair
of the trust fund uh I think the desire
was to to have this become a an ongoing
thing and they wanted my understanding
uh you know a blessing of the the
general court so with that I'm happy to
answer any questions you have
um and again representative Boyd I know
he wanted to be here I know he said some
Communications but he asked me to be
here
acquire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming so this is a new chapter but you
say you're already doing it right we are
doing this as a kind of a pilot program
through the drinking water groundwater
trust fund
Oasis sure so so no money has been this
is a new fund right so therefore okay
right I believe the intent of this
legislation is that they have funding
other than the the drinking water
groundwater trust fund and into a
special account exactly okay
um now I went to the website for this
thing and it said no droughts currently
correct okay all right
um thank you
representative Griffin involved by Ebel
so if if we were were to have a drought
this some
uh could you still draw from the
drinking water trust fund
we have some monies remaining in the
trust fund I I to be to be blunt if if
this program were to continue we'd need
another infusion from the trust fund
further question or
represent evil
clarify thank you for being here could
you just clarify what the original
funding source was for the drinking
water and groundwater trust fund and the
extent of the fund sure so if we go back
in time uh we we're still grappling with
it but I think well uh we've had a lot
of issues with mtbe contamination which
is a additive of gasoline the Attorney
General's office and a lot of the staff
with the our agency Des spent a lot of
time with the the manufacturers uh in
distribute Distributors if you will of
mtbe so there were two elements of that
there was a short answer is uh MTB
obscure
I was going to say MTV mobile I get that
wrong they don't want to be called that
at all
mobile Corp uh effectively uh did not
settle with the state uh that they ended
up going to court they lost the the
Court ruling provided Monies to the
state uh to the tune of 300 million
dollars or so uh between a certain
amount of that once the rainy day fund
uh and the the rest of that went uh to
the drinking water groundwater trust
fund that was a legislatively uh
established and that's that's the where
the monies for that come from the trust
fund by Statute is able to is able to
address things more than just MTB
contamination and is geared towards uh
by definition and statute to address
represent Maguire
well I want to talk about the bill
itself I don't really haven't worked
much
oh representative thank you Mr chair
um so you said that some 300 million
dollars were given based on the lawsuit
and
I heard you mention earlier that
recently you allocated 3.1 million to
help out with well situations where'd
the rest of the 300 million go so
there's currently 108 million roughly
still in the drinking water groundwater
trust fund uh that has been
the intent of that fund has been to we
we issue loans and grants to drinking
water systems uh and drinking water
issues so it's sort of obviously the
loan money comes back on the long term
so there's an intent there to have a
certain certain amount of refreshing uh
but out of the original amount that's
gone to the trust fund there's currently
108 million that's unallocated and
typically this is a 19 person Commission
uh typically it used to be uh chaired by
uh
um the Senate President at the time and
now obviously uh representative Boyd
um so we typically try to allocate
roughly 20 million or so a year
towards uh projects they're they're
effectively ranked and and judged by the
19 person commission and then awarded
based on them
so
and as the rest of the money sitting is
it gaining interest and also if you were
on the loans what percent do you charge
uh for a Payback
no that's a good question so so yes so
the state treasurer invests the the
funds to to make sure there's some
you know the money's working if you will
if it's not being allocated and I'm
trying to remember some the the I'm
going to look behind me because I have
some staff so so I think it's at current
rates is what is this it's uh loan loan
to them but I'm gonna ask uh Brandon if
yeah if you could just come up and take
the mic please
and again identify yourself for the
record sorry I don't want to complicate
things I want to give you a correct
good afternoon I'm Brandon Kernan I'm
the ministrator of drinking water and
groundwater Bureau des and to answer the
question the interest rate established
each year based on a publication I
believe in November I'd have to go to
the exact date right now the interest
rate's around 3.1 percent but it'll
obviously be adjusted upward this year
represent Maguire I think you had
something right
yeah I wanted to just discuss the bill
if there's all right yeah so
um
I'm opposed to this bill and I I have
two specific reasons
um first is House Rules
so in the house rule number 45 Part D it
says no committee shall Report with
positive recommendation any bill or
resolution which would if it enacted
violate any article of the New Hampshire
Constitution or the United States
Constitution or and this is the key part
Grant broad rule making authority to any
agency or Department the vice chairman
or another member of each committee
shall review all pending legislation and
shall advise the chairman and the
members of all legislation before the
committee which could be reviewed in
terms of this rule so this Rule and on
as the vice chairman
this rule has classic broad rule-making
Authority if you look at the line 27
it says the commissional shall adopt
rules under 5 541a relative to the
distribution of money from the fund
taking into consideration ability to pay
natural disaster conditions Etc et
cetera and then the department may use a
portion of a of appropriated funds to
cover the costs of administering this
chapter so this this doesn't tell the
department
it doesn't Define what a disaster is it
doesn't say how much each
recipient of money can get it doesn't
say how it's spent and who it goes to
all that sort of stuff
um
is not specified all right so that's
what we call broad rulemaking Authority
so according to house rules we shouldn't
approve this bill
um as written it needs a lot more detail
in that section
but my second reason is
um
I just don't think this is a good idea
in the sense that
this is this would be a five million
dollar pot of money sort of waiting
around for a disaster to happen
right I mean when do you ever do that do
do you you know I have a well at home I
don't have a separate bank account
waiting for when that well is going to
you know need need help I don't know
when a flood is going to occur et cetera
et cetera in general when disasters
happen that's when we we allocate money
and get charity and get finma and all
that sort of stuff and that's when we
decide what to do I mean if we had a
fire
this money would be sitting there and
and you know we'd need other money to to
deal with that kind of disaster so so I
just don't think it makes sense to have
a very specific you know money for some
very specific kind of disaster so I want
okay it's been moved and seconded uh
there is discussion I have some
questions
for the commissioner if you commissioner
Scott
yes Mr charity
so representative McGuire pointed out
the RSA
541 with the broad rule making Authority
you've obviously had bills before us
before with
broad rule making authorities this
language less restrictive than we've
seen or more restrictive or
or something similar we've seen from you
folks in the past when there's an issue
like this
I don't know what I can answer that I
don't think it's unprecedented but I
certainly understand the representatives
uh questions again the the intent was we
are effectively running an existing
program and we'd be lifting those those
requirements in our rule making so that
that's certainly the attention uh but
the the 45 d uh question is is out of my
um further to that I had a good
discussion with former Senate President
Morse a few days ago about this bill and
he encouraged us to support it because
it's been such a successful program and
allows the department to act quickly
especially in light of the present
droughts that we have experienced over
the last several years is that how you
folks look at this that it gives you the
funds available immediately to address a
lack of water issue versus having to
come back for a special appropriation of
fiscal or filing legislation I think
that's a fair fair assessment you know
again I've been trying to as
commissioner I've been trying to be very
clear with all the Committees I
understand you have a lot of uses for
monies and whatnot but as far as the
program we certainly support the program
and think it's very worthwhile we again
it's the intent is for
low-income qualifying people that don't
have access to you know there's no FEMA
money there's no insurance money Etc and
unfortunately again we've seen this as a
as a need throughout the state I am
concerned we're going to go to year four
of severe drought uh and you know again
I I would be very pleased to be wrong
and the other the other intent of again
through the trust fund was again the
representative McGuire is not wrong
there is some intent to have
to have some pot of money where the
agency could be more agile while FEMA
and everybody else was coming into place
a good example would be you know you
have a major hurricane hits the Seacoast
and some wells are salinated so they're
no longer they're they're damaged to the
point where you there's nothing to be
done for them
there's needs needs that happen
quicker so there's an element of both
both to that
I guess just a suggestion for the
division I think uh representative
McGuire's raised some good points it
would be my hope that maybe
representative McGuire can get together
with you folks and tidy up this language
on rule making Authority
sure representative Griffin
thank you this is not a question but
apparently the program that existed has
not expired
and apparently
the fund that the money was coming from
is still there has some 108 million
dollars in that I guess
and uh
so I don't see where
itl in this bill
is is a disaster if we have a drought
this summer
the program still exists the money is
all right any further comments uh
we do have a motion before us not seeing
any
oh I'm sorry representative Ebola
thank you I just wondered if the
commissioner could comment on
representative Griffin's observation
that there are funds that remain in the
trust fund and why you're establishing a
different channel so to speak
as I mentioned in my earlier remarks I
think the intent from the the current
former chairs uh was to to have a
legislative imprint on on this program
we've started it it's been running three
years we feel it's been successful and
needed uh the the
People Help throughout the state are
truly all over the state the the the the
uh the drought's been running severe in
different parts of the state each year
uh and I think the intent was to to have
that imprint in in buy-in by the
legislature rather than have it being
kind of an off the side program
um so yes correct there there are funds
still in the trust fund uh and my guess
would be
you know we would need it if if this was
itl'd and nothing moved forward again
I'm I'm always happy to work with any
legislator so certainly I'd work with uh
representative McGuire if you if you
were interested uh but we'd have to go
back to the trust fund uh make the case
there and and again I can't speak for
the trust fund there's 19 Commissioners
is there any reason why money from the
trust fund couldn't be transferred to
find out to finance this separate
program
when you say transferred is that the
trust fund as opposed to new money new
general funds
this so again I'd there's a 19 person
commission they would need to vote right
but if they did There's okay
because they're recommending that this
be created right correct
Zen of Griffin
as representative herbal's point
um I think that would take away some
flexibility
that money would be locked up for a
specific purpose where right now it's
not locked up they have some flexibility
and again I'm just thinking back to my
conversation with former president Morse
I think he wanted more of a legislative
hand in this versus
yes representative Sweeney thank you Mr
just to add to the discussion I think
there are parts of the bill and parts of
the policy that uh could be more ironed
out to address the rule-making issues
that representative McGuire put together
and and maybe the the funding
appropriation versus where it's coming
from and and how we work the the fiscal
note out uh because it really doesn't
show a
planned increase in expenditures or rev
obviously revenues both interterminal
increase
I think it's a policy and I know we're
not the policy committee for this
legislation uh it's a policy that could
have some wrinkles ironed out and
whether or not if we itl this bill today
uh I guess publicly for the record I
want to say my willingness to work on
addressing concerns in the policy
outside of this bill maybe or whatnot in
order to empower the commission to do
what they seek to do and get that
legislative process in place
on the on the way that we handle this
um so if we're italing it right now
we're telling it maybe uh
but I think the other underlying parts
of it can live on somewhere else
potentially or we can retain and work on
the rule making issues for the bill
that's my two cents
representative McGuire thank you see and
this is why
it's not up to us to decide
um
exactly who gets what under what
conditions and so on that's a lot of
policy right you know maybe it's not
just drought maybe it's also what he
talked about storm storm damage that's
not a drought that's something else
right but but you need to have in the in
a law that spends money you need to have
details and there's there's like nothing
here so that's the problem I mean I I
don't see any
yes they can come back next year
right with a with a more detailed bill
or the year after you know it doesn't
seem like a problem
my only if if we itl this can they come
back next year with a similar policy or
would they have to wait two years
it would thank you for the question but
it would have to be it's a decision of
the speaker
as to whether it was sufficiently
different right and I think what
personally I would think if it
specifically said people you know with
this income this much money a lot of a
lot more stuff that's that's
sufficiently different okay so but it'd
all right is there any more discussion
there is a motion on the floor of itl
that was made by representative McGuire
seconded by representative Griffin I
believe
tall enough
all right when the clerk is ready please
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative Hewitt no
and representative leishman
all right uh itl on the bill
foreign
McGuire you have another committee
the investigation testing and monitoring
of pfas
Mr Hoffman a little history thanks
the report out of resources Recreation
and development was ought to pass with a
vote of 20-0 and the Full House
all right I see representative wrong
okay
we'll just wait until Mr Hoffman gets
here
handout passed around
oh
so this Rowdy crew generally spends a
lot of time on the fiscal impact so
try to keep your comments to the fiscal
impact because it sounds like the policy
committee supported it overwhelmingly
yes thank you very much Mr chairman for
the record my name is Rosemary wrong I
represent
Hillsborough 12 which is the town of
Merrimack and I'll keep my remarks brief
because there are two people behind me
from Des that can speak more about the
financing of this fund this would be
adding two million dollars to an
existing fund that provides testing and
Remediation for pfas contamination
up until December I chaired the HB 737
commission that studied the health and
environmental impacts of pfas
contamination that resulted from a
contamination from the Merrimac
operations of Sanko Bain performance
Plastics and the commission made three
recommendations last fall and I'll
report to the governor and one of them
was to expand the on so that it can be
responsive to anticipated regulation
coming from EPA this year which I just
saw a snippet today in the news that
that those those are going to be
imminent so this would prepare Des to be
able to respond to those new standards
also to expand the application of the
fund since the original consent decree
was agreed upon between the state and
sanco Bain
contamination has been discovered beyond
the outer boundary of that consent
degree so DS has taken responsibility
for a lot of the testing and Remediation
of those of the private Wells and
they're working with the town of
Londonderry on Municipal Water
projects or initiatives
so essentially this two million dollars
would be used to increase the current
fund and increase the application of the
intent of the of what that fund's
intended for
and I would be happy to answer any
questions but I do know that Mr wimsat
and Ms Russo are behind me and they live
this almost every day the
I'll see if there's any questions for
you of course thank you representative
Griffin
my question really goes to uh LBA I
think
if there's an existing phone and it's
called the pfas fund Loan Fund somewhere
it has to be renamed right does that
yeah the bill does rename the fund to
the pfas response fund from The Loan
Fund
but I don't see that in here what I see
is
I see some changes but I don't see a
line that says
The pfas Loan Fund will now be called
I don't know okay
I I don't I don't read that as changing
the fun name
as it says the Reese read the pfas
response fund means
that I don't know why it just doesn't
it is a little confusing because loan
response it's all providing money
probably cut up the pie I suppose
uh representative McGuire you had a
question well I just I'll just answer
that question so on the second page on
line 14 you see that's that's the
section h10 which defines the fund right
where it says fund established you see
that
transfer
well in 29 it says the sum of two
million dollars for fiscal year ending
June 30th of this year by appropriate to
yes anyone who represents Sweden thank
you Mr my reading of it I I'm going to
assume RSA
485-8 H with the you know colon numbers
that is what established the Loan Fund
and we are amending it to response fund
without re right without needing it's
just
so I think that the way I read it is the
funds don't aren't moving they're just
does anyone have any idea what's in that
fund now
um I'm going to defer to Mr whimsat Ms
Russo because she administers it all
whomever
foreign
for the record my name is Mike wimsat I
service director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire Des with me
is Amy Russo who administers our pfas uh
response the the the mediation Loan Fund
but really is our services our pfas
coordinator across all of our state
operations addressing pfas the direct
answer to your question is that there's
approximately 22 million dollars
remaining in the pfas remediation Loan
Fund an important distinction that I
would draw is that those funds were
appropriated very specifically by the
legislature
solely for the use for for
administering the Loan Fund
administering loans that was when the
fund was first established about three
years ago in the next year the
legislature the the the statute was
amended to provide the authority to also
make grants from The Loan Fund but that
initial appropriation that was not
amended so we see that as being solely
there and available to make loans and
those loans would be made to eligible
water systems for improvements that have
been impacted by pfas contamination to
make improvements and install treatment
to address the pfas contamination
subsequently there was money
appropriated to make grants and so we
and that is largely spoken for the
grants are as they often are very
popular there's a lot of water systems a
lot of small community water systems and
and larger public water systems that had
to spend a lot of money to address pfas
contamination so that's largely
accounted for and then in the next year
the legislature the
statute was further amended to provide
Authority for Des to administer a very
specific pfas mediation rebate program
and that program is to provide rebates
of up to five thousand dollars per
property
for any any property owner whose private
well is impact affected by pfas
contamination can get is eligible to get
if they're not being addressed by a
responsible party and not being provided
with alternate Water by another party
then they're eligible to apply for a
rebate to offset their own costs
incurred to put treatment on their well
to address pfas contamination or if
they're fortunate enough to live close
to a public water system close enough to
connect in without a large expenditure
they can get up to a ten thousand dollar
rebate to offset the cost of that
connection so that's a lot more than
maybe you're counting on but that's
that's where this is at right now
so that would lead me to the question
you said there's 22 million dollars
right now available in this other fund
rough layer no so yeah so this bill
would as as the committee has discussed
here change the name of the fund to the
pfas response fund and that's not just
to
give it another name is to expand its
scope to include the ability to use
funds that are appropriated for that
purpose to do additional work to
determine occurrence of pfas whether
it's soil or
um uh you know fish or or you know
basically all the other or air basically
we've had to spend a lot of resources as
best we could to evaluate the occurrence
of pfas across the whole environment not
just drinking water and we basically had
about a six million dollar appropriation
that was dedicated to that that is
lapsing at the end of this fiscal year
so in just three through four months
here so we will no longer have funds
available that are dedicated to doing
the kind of work we've been doing we you
know we we've been directed to uh by the
legislature to establish soil
remediation standards and we had to do a
lot of work to educate ourselves about
the occurrence in soil understand how
the pfas behaves in soil so we used
Appropriations from that six million to
do some of the studies in the work the
background work that we needed to do to
understand what we need in order to to
do a good job setting an appropriate
soil standard we've also used those
funds again for fish tissue studies
shellfish tissue studies in the Great
Bay and a number of other and also our
bile solids program has used these funds
to essentially
um study land application of wastewater
treatment sludges what's coming into and
going out of wastewater treatment plants
so that's a separate money that's going
away what I think this bill is trying to
do is say okay this pfaster mediation
Loan Fund which up to now is only
available for making loans and grants
for very specific purposes that are tied
solely to drinking water
and and also Wastewater but those are
the two areas that it can go to
this is trying to broaden the scope of
it so that funds that are appropriated
for for that purpose can also be
deposited to this fund and used for that
additional work that we've been doing
using the six million dollars that is
now lapsing basically
represent a Sweeney followed by
representative Weiler thank you Mr
chairman thank you both for being here
to take our questions so I'm reading the
physical note and it's a two million
dollar appropriation from fiscal year 23
and you mentioned the Six Million Dollar
appropriation that laps in the current
fund and the funding source is general
and the pfas response fund so but what
you just said I gather the 22 million
dollars without legislation goes down to
16 million dollars
by June and then this would really just
bring it back to 18 or no no we're
talking about and I apologize it's
confusing it's two separate pots of
money The Six Million never went into
this fund that is a separate
appropriation that was appropriated
directly to the department
um and we budgeted for it and it's in
our but it's in our it's in our
operating budget
um so so the the important I think thing
thing to understand is that
while there have been funds appropriated
to this fund they are all specifically
have ties to the the original 50 million
which is now 22 million we're solely for
loans to Water Systems the grant
allocation was solely to water systems
for for for for making improvements to
address pfas there are no funds in this
fund as it's currently comprised that
are allowed to be used for those broader
purposes
for other question oh thank you and an
apologies this might be a question for
LBA or someone else but
so this bill doesn't change the
guidelines on the 22 million dollar
appropriation right there's still going
to be four loans and this two million
dollars will be for Grants yes that's
correct uh no this wouldn't necessarily
be for Grants this would be money it
could be used
no this would be really for operating
expenses to do or it could be for
contractual for example if we are a
contractor to sample shellfish or
something like that is could be used for
a lot I'll give you an example
um and one of the the real benefits of
having this kind of money available is
that we can Leverage The Investments get
a lot more in return for example about
ninety thousand dollars of this six
million was provided to Dartmouth
College
um to as part of a half a million dollar
study on fish tissue and and shellfish
so we're going to get all the data
associated with a half a million dollar
study for a 90 000 investment so um the
the real Advantage the real problem
we're having right now is with this six
million lapsing we're not in a position
to do this kind of work moving forward
because we don't have any funding
sources that um are are useful are
representative Weiler followed by
Griffin and Evil
thank you
so we've got everybody in the in the
whole population stirred up about the
dangers of pfas which is so prevalent we
probably all have it in our body anyway
we do but you have failed to do any
examination
in the population of the blood the
amount of everybody's blood especially
looking at firemen who are most exposed
that that's a big remiss and a few years
ago I called up and said why are we the
lowest at 12 parts per trillion which to
me is infinitesimal 12 parts per
trillion and I was referred to some PhD
named Jonathan I can't remember his name
and I said can you refer me to the data
or the study that that supports 12 parts
per trillion
and he didn't he just said look it up
I thought
that to me means there isn't one it's
just BS
so if you're going to go and say oh
we've got to do something spend billions
of dollars cleaning out pfast which we
never can because it's so prevalent
you need to do data among our population
to assure them and take a look at the
health of people especially Saint Cobain
and firemen to come and come and tell us
what have been the effects and has
anybody found a way to treat it and has
it been successful
like sometimes chelation and things like
this have removed these sorts of things
from our body
that's what you should be do spending
this money on not saying oh we've got to
fix this water system we've got to fix
that water system to this ridiculous 12
parts per trillion when arsenic can be
20 parts per million that's a million
times more
and yet we got it all excited in
spending millions of dollars and you
haven't given us any reason
that there's a real health problem I'm
really glad you asked that question
representative Weiler um and there's a
lot to unpack there but I'll try to try
to answer as as in a helpful way if I
can
um I agree there's a lot of information
out there that that is you know
unfortunately when something like this
hits the news there's an article every
day every day there's a new allegation
that it's toilet paper or it's whatever
you know every day there's a new thing
that that's loaded with pfast that's
killing us and that's one of the reasons
that we've elected to do is careful of
study as we can on specific issues so
that we can sort through that because we
can't rely on the media to tell us what
the problems are and and there's so many
people some who are really not reliable
doing studies and Publishing studies
that it becomes very difficult so
there's a certain
a requirement for us to and frankly in
the beginning of this nobody was doing
much work so we were you know here we
were a little New Hampshire but we had
this outsized problem in Southern New
Hampshire with the emissions from a
particular facility and um we really had
to get these answers quickly so we were
we weren't doing blood testing and I'll
speak to that in a moment but we spent
whatever resources we had immediately we
had Des staff knocking on doors on the
weekend you know offering to sample
people's Wells because suddenly we
realized we had a problem that was much
greater than we ever had seen before
because of the air emissions nature of
how this was emitted it had
impacted Wells as we later learned over
dozens of square miles and we don't have
any sites like that in New Hampshire
that have done anything like that
they're all much more localized so um
with regard to the the standard I'm
sorry I I hope you didn't get that kind
of a response we do have staff who have
worked very hard done the science on
this and and I will I'll push firstly
make sure you get in touch with someone
who can sit down with you and walk you
through how we develop that standard I
will tell you there are a number of
other states that have developed
standards that are much in line with
that the uscpa right now is working on a
proposed standard that must maybe much
lower than that and we're going to look
at that we're going to try to understand
that when that proposal comes
but the advantage of having the ability
to well I want to go to the issue of
blood testing so that's not something
that has really been in Des as well
wheelhouse before we sample water we
sample soil and drinking water and
wastewater we don't draw blood and take
blood samples from people the Department
of Health and Human Services has done
that to some degree maybe not to the
satisfaction of some communities and
also on the Sea Coast because of this
issue that occurred at peace Tradeport
which was actually our first discovery
of this back in 2014 our Congressional
Delegation has allocated federal funds
to do blood testing and there have been
efforts to do blood testing of folks who
worked on the trade Port over the last
40 years or so so there is work I I'll
be quick to say it's probably not enough
but again that's not in our wheelhouse
we're not Public Health experts follow
up
so when I did look up the available uh
studies at the time
they were all about mice and other
Critters
and almost every one of them at the time
I read them a few years ago said human
studies need to be done
so maybe they've been done since but I
haven't really looked up to see but if
human studies haven't need to be done
why do we assume we're in danger
and if I may and I want to I want to
preface my remarks by saying I'm not a
toxicologist so these are not expert
remarks for me but what but I've been
living this since 2016 on a daily basis
and and talking to the folks who do know
and what I'll tell you a couple things
first of all it's not very satisfying
but many of the standards that we we put
on drinking water or soil you know
contact whatever it might be are based
on animal studies that's because we
don't we don't do studies on humans
right we so the only time we get human
data is when we have an exposed
population and in the case of pfas we do
have a couple of very significant
exposed populations that occurred down
in West Virginia and the Ohio Valley
um
well right and and that that study
hasn't been done yet but these were
people who were near a plant that
manufactured these compounds and had it
in their drinking water and it was a
large study it was somewhere on the
order of I think oh gosh I think there's
over 80 000 people that were involved in
the study so that's that's big they
weren't able to draw as often happens
absolute conclusions and causality but
they did see associations in the
exposure the exposed population with the
occurrence of certain disease and health
impacts so that often that's As Good As
It Gets In terms of confidence level for
something so again I'm not going to
defend that because I it's not my area
of expertise but we we do have a
combination of intensive animal studies
that have been done and some
epidemiological data in humans and the
experts who know a lot more than this
about this than me when they evaluated
all of that and it's not just New
Hampshire we're not on our own on this
we relied on the the work of a number of
other states and and we and we were
working to develop these numbers we also
brought in we hired a toxicologist who
works for the agency but we also hired a
contract toxicologist very bright guys
Steve Roberts from from the University
of Florida who who consulted with us on
this so we had a lot of very high power
people working on this and at the end of
the day that's where we landed um and
that you know and it's hard to imagine I
think that it's hard to wrap your head
around how something could be so
dangerous at parts per trillion but the
problem with pfas as I understand it is
that unlike a lot of other contaminants
that kind of hide out in the body fat
and don't really sort of interact with
your metabolism and that's a that's a
Layman's way of describing it pfas is in
the blood which means it gets
distributed throughout your body it gets
in contact with all your organs because
your blood is your is your
transportation system for the body so as
a result and when you talk about it in
drinking water where you even though
it's a small amount you know the average
human is drinking you know through food
and drink and everything else getting a
couple liters or more a day of water it
adds up and the problem the other
problem with these compounds that make
them separate from other contaminants is
that they're so durable the pfas can
compound the carbon fluorine Bond just
doesn't go away it doesn't break down so
you know the pfast that you ate or drank
10 years ago you know a good portion but
still in your body today which isn't
true any of this money go toward human
studies like maybe through Dartmouth
medical school if we were directed to do
that we again we don't necessarily see
that as our area of expertise but
certainly if the legislature saw fit to
allocate Monies to Des that would be
used to work in concert with our Health
Partners or or maybe directly to the AHS
who was also a partner with us in this
fight against these these compounds and
we certainly we we'd be happy to pursue
that thank you
representative Griffin you know thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
the question
um
it was a little confusing when you got
into the operating fund versus the
b-fest on sure but I think what you've
told us is
that the original pfas Loan Fund
as some 22 million dollars in it
and this law is broadening the use of
that money
so that it can be used
for uh
investigation testing and monitoring I
think that's almost right I believe that
what this law would do would be to
broaden the scope of available of
eligible activities to use this fund for
but the 22 million dollars as we read it
was specifically appropriated for loans
and we don't believe that even if this
bill passes we could use that 22 million
for the broad and scope of capability of
of of eligible activities in this bill
and that's why
as we see it if the bill passes it would
make the fund in and of itself a broader
have a more comprehensive scope but in
order to do those additional compreh
additional activities that would need to
be an additional appropriation that was
so you're not anticipating having two
separate funds you have one fund no no
sir that that's exactly right and and
there's plenty of um examples of this in
state government there are dedicated
funds that have a broad broad categories
of usage but individual amounts may be
appropriated to that fund that have a
more narrow scope and we have systems in
place for managing that so that we don't
try you know we don't have using monies
from the wrong Pots if you will I I
understand I I read you clearly right so
my last question is my really my first
question I'm the state treasurer sitting
down there with this fund and you come
to me and say you got to rename the fun
you're going to make it the response
fund well you got to create a response
fund and transfer the money to it where
is the Authority for that I don't see
yeah I will tell you I'm not a
parliamentarian expert here my my
understanding is that the bill
accomplishes that by saying that the the
part of the bill that establishes the
fund
is amended to change the name of the
fund I think essentially by action of
law if this bill were to pass the front
the pfas rlf wouldn't would no longer
exist and it would be called the pfas
response fund and it would just the
monies remain in the fund as they are
the treasurer essentially manages those
funds in aggregate but the agency would
through its internal accounting
procedures ensure that it only expended
the individual pots of money in the fund
percent of evil
had so much discussion since I thought
of my question I gotta just kind of
think of it here I think you asked a lot
of the questions I guess
um regardless of the amount that's
appropriated whether it was 2 million or
1 million or zero million and I'm not
saying it should be zero million is it
you're feeling that this bill should
pass because you really want to change
the scope of the fund
yeah the verbiage because right thank
you for the question yes we we in our in
our original testimony in the policy
committee you know as you heard from
commissioner Scott we're just really not
taking positions on Appropriations
generally this session
um but with respect to the policy
aspects of this yes we think it's
important that this fund
um be
um that its uses be broadened so that we
have a clear directive really what it
gives us is a directive from the
legislature that yes doing this work is
important work and that when the six
million dollars was appropriated that's
what we got from the from the
legislature we've got a directive that
we want you to go and use this money to
learn more and understand the occurrence
of pfas understand the exposure Pathways
to humans so that you can make good
policy and and come to the legislature
if laws need to be changed and advise
the legislature on what you think needs
to happen so yes we we think that this
would essentially renew that directive
even if it you know didn't initially
come with with funding
further question so we keep asking and I
think we're all sort of figuring it out
on our own so the 22 million you really
consider kind of locked down for loans
and grants that's correct and Loans only
loans sort of but is that in statute are
you just if you go back to the law that
appropriated the money it says 50
million dollars shall be appropriated to
make loans to eligible Water Systems
right so we think that's pretty clear
follow-up and this bill doesn't change
that I don't believe it does no okay
just one more and then so the 2 million
really is to kind of take the place of
the 6 million which you've used that's a
that's a that's a reasonable way to look
at it yes okay
thank you
represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman so um I I think we
should retain this bill
um
and put this most of this language of
the renaming Etc into House Bill 2 and
decide on the money because
um if we I we don't necessarily have to
keep all 22 million for loans let me ask
this question how much did how much loan
funds did you originally have when was
that occur how much have you loaned out
to get to the 22 million do you want to
speak to that Amy because that's your
your expertise yeah so the original loan
amount was 50 million dollars
um we have to date loaned out
approximately 23 or we've approved 23
million in loan today so we have 22
million left
we have need for that 22 million but in
the interim as Mike has described we
have the ability to now give grants and
we've received appropriation for Grants
so that grant money has been moving
faster than the loan money so now that
the grant money is mostly allocated
um most of the applicants that are going
to be coming in in the future will be
taking loan those loan funds rather than
Grant funds
so someone can have one or the other but
not both is that the way it works so the
way that the program is set up through
statue is that grants go out first to a
total of 1.5 million dollars or 30 of
the total cost of the project whichever
is greater so most of the grants that we
have given to date have been that 1.5
million dollars there are a few that are
at the 30 percent
um so we we give the grant first and
then if the total cost of the project is
greater that is then given out in loan
when did you start with 50 million
um you said 20 you've loaned out 23
and you have 22 left from 50. so there's
I mean I've got my
okay yeah
yeah all right so there is 22 million
left left okay I am a certain so you
went out so 28 this has been loaned yeah
yeah and when will it but that'll be
paid back and go back into the fund yes
that is the intent yes as those loans
are being repaid it would go back into
the fund are they 10-year loans or what
are they uh 20 or 30 years depending on
I'll second that motion
okay the Motions been made by
representative McGuire second if I
representative evil is there a
discussion
sure representative rules thank you Mr
chair uh going back to the six million
dollars has that been is completely
exhausted or is it gonna you said it was
going to lapse in June if so how much
money is left in that account
so it is it is going to lapse in June we
are on schedule to expend all of the Six
Million you're going to spend it all yes
okay and back to uh representative
McGuire's question uh in terms of the
loans that have been made have them have
they been getting paid back or do you
have defaults and if so what percentage
of default do you have on the loans so
none are in repayment at this point the
projects are still ongoing
either they have not started
construction or they're in construction
now
I just have one question where did all
the initial money come from
was that some federal money state money
something from Saint colbain the initial
50 million for the loans no that was a
general fund appropriation
or by bonding it was at this part of
primary capital budget
can I just file so uh the grant money it
was also put in this fund
yes that's correct and I'm top of my
head you have those grant numbers on
your head yes so um last legislative
session 25 million was appropriated for
the grant portion of this
um and as Mike had mentioned earlier the
rebate program was added to the statute
so that 25 million of Grant where some
of it's towards the grant towards the
pfas remediation Loan Fund some of it we
are using for the rebate program
was that also bonded
that was a general fund Surplus
appropriation
describing I think it would help us
there's a lot of people so immersed in
this they know it like the back of their
hands but when we're looking at this I
know I would find that helpful
you've given us a lot of information in
the half an hour or so thanks I
appreciate that we're lucky to have both
of you by the way very I've known
Michael a long time
lucky to have his expertise
so we do have a motion uh to retain it's
been moved and seconded when the clerk
is ready please call the roll or just
have a show of hands with her it's going
to stay within the division so everybody
okay with retain
it's unanimous thank you we'll look
forward to your
several paragraphs that's your early
also um let's see representative rung is
still here so this is uh house bill 276.
Mr Hoffman if we could have a quick
docket history please
yes House Bill 276
came out of the resources Recreation
and development committee with ought to
pass with Amendment a vote of 17-3
and then it
passed the Full House on a vote of 199
thank you Mr Hoffman
representative rung I think I saw
something being handed out from you or
about to
yeah
um just for the record I'm Rosemary rung
I represent Hillsboro 12 which is the
town of Merrimack I'm just passing out
the testimony I provided to the
resources committee when this was
introduced to the policy
um
last year there was a bill passed
HB 1066 which addresses the growing
threat of cyanobacteria blooms in the
state of New Hampshire
cyanobacteria blooms you may be aware
growing problem globally and
particularly in the last several years
we've seen very disturbing trend of
increased blooms in New Hampshire
waterways primarily New Hampshire Lakes
um aside from the health and
environmental impact these blooms have
um they they have a tremendous impact on
our economy as well
um uh Pat tarpy who is executive
director of Lake Winnipesaukee
Association is behind me and she can
speak to a specific economic study that
was done and also Andrea lomino who is
the executive director of New Hampshire
lakes and they've been tracking this
issue very closely for the last several
years
but I brought forth this bill because
the
um in HP 1066 Des is charged with
creating a plan to address and mitigate
cyanobacteria blooms and that report is
due in November but it is with certainty
that it's going to come with cost and so
I I wanted to introduce this bill to get
a fund in place and I'm glad we've heard
about the pfas loan and Remediation fund
and the drinking water and groundwater
trust fund because I mirrored this bill
after those funds which would provide
loans and grants to municipalities
Municipal Water Systems and water and
Watershed and Lake Associations to
implement programs and projects to lower
the contributors that lead to
cyanobacterial blooms and probably the
biggest contributor is phosphorus
phosphorus can come from failing septic
systems at the shoreline it could come
from runoff
um
uh it could come from waste waterfowl
waste there's there's a lot of sources
for
um phosphorus loading into a lake and
serving as a catalyst for these blooms
and as we saw this year with Lake
Winnipesaukee they essentially did not
have an ice in and so it is expected
with that increased water temperature
that this is going to be a severe year
for blooms and if we can't Finance
projects that are currently have already
been identified to reduce the phosphorus
it's just exacerb exacerbates the
problem in years to come because
phosphorus is an element it doesn't
break down if it's added to a lake it's
going to contr can increase the
concentration of that phosphorus so the
sooner we can mitigate phosphorus being
added into a lake the less likely a
bloom is going to occur
um
what the way many of these Lake and
Watershed associations have
um funded mitigation projects is
essentially they do it on their own with
limited funds they get a lot of
volunteers
um they pay for their own watershed
management plans which are very
professionally done studies of the of us
of a water body that identify sources of
phosphorus and outline projects to
mitigate it
they've been doing the the they've been
funding the watershed management plans
essentially on their own there there's
some limited funds available but they
are very limited and pretty much don't
have access to funds to actually do the
mitigation projects so this would be a
fund that could fund some of those
projects right out of the gate and also
serve to fund the projects that come out
of that 1066 report that's due in
November
um I don't there there is some limited
funding from the state and I'm sorry
commissioner Scott left but it's there's
some federal funds that come into the
state under it's called 319 funds
they're extremely competitive
um they don't fund a lot of quality
projects because it's very very limited
um and every year the applications for
those funds grows because this is a
excuse the pond but a blooming problem
and
um so I think having this Fund in place
to address cyanobacteria
um it is important to get this money in
place because there's nothing we can do
that isn't going to come with a price
tag another important point I want to
raise is that I think at least 23
municipalities in the state rely on
surface water for their drinking water
sources and they are really not prepared
to address blooms last year Arlington
Pond which serves as a drinking water
source for the town of Salem experienced
a severe Bloom they were able to
transfer their intake to Canopy Lake
there was a bloom at Bow Lake but I
anticipate that what's going to come out
of the November report is and I'm sure
that some water systems are considering
now is developing a plan B either trying
to find groundwater sources but
something they can use in the event a
bloom impacts their their intake
so I'd be happy to answer any questions
represent McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative when you develop this um
plan did you consider
maybe more of a punitive
approach rather than the grant loan type
thing in the sense of if people are
putting phosphorus into the water then
they get fined
thank you for the question there was a
bill a couple years ago that addressed
Shoreline septic systems and because
many times these fail and people don't
know because it's just going into the
water and and historically phosphorus
has not been a problem in New Hampshire
but it's a variable that we can control
because we can't control the temperature
of the lakes and rivers and those
increasing temperatures even if we
didn't if phosphorus was the same we
would still be having Bloom so we have
to reduce the phosphorus in the lake
um punitive
um I don't really know I I wish
commissioner Scott had stayed because I
I think the enforcement of current
regulations is an area that we should
look at but
um this this fund would also be used for
actual even in-link treatment systems
for instance nippo Lake in Barrington
has had severe cyanobacteria blooms for
the past 10 years and their Lake
Association had worked very hard
implementing projects to reduce
phosphorus but it wasn't enough because
there's another component called
internal loading that can happen
I don't want to go into all the science
I'd be happy to but I don't want to take
up your time now now but the state
actually worked with nippo Lake getting
funds to do what's called an Alum
treatment and they spray Alum on and it
settles and it locks in the internal
loading source of phosphorus that that's
in the sediment and it's been very
successful they did one years ago on
Kaiser Lake which was actually an um a
source where effluent Wastewater
effluent it used to go into that Lake
and it's severe problems so those
treatments run up to a half a million
dollars and there may be some water
bodies that are so impaired that they
may need an in-link treatment and this
would would cover that as well I know
Silver Lake and Hollis is essentially
that's a state park and I don't really
know if it's been open much in the past
few years between E coli
contamination and cyanobacteria blooms
that's likely going to be a that that
would probably qualify for in-link
treatment and at the moment
municipalities and Lake Associations and
Watershed associations just don't have
access to the capital needed to fund
so are you thinking of this money as
being some loans to to improve septic
systems and some grants to do this these
treatments of lakes is that kind of
initially before this bill was amended
it was purely a Loan Fund and I modeled
it after
um the pfas mitigation Loan Fund but
what came out in the the Committee
hearing was that and and this was a
concern commissioner Scott raised is
that there is some associations that can
Implement projects but they wouldn't
qualify for a loan so my intent would be
that small associations that have
identified projects from an EPA approved
watershed management plan could access a
grant component of this but
municipalities and Municipal Water
Systems could get a grant similar to
what we heard
regarding the pfas fund so it would be a
hybrid of a grant Loan program depending
on the organization that would be
applying and also the ranking of the
project
if there are you know water bodies in
New Hampshire have some have been
identified as being impaired and some at
risk and so for instance if there's a a
lake that is
strategic to the economy of New
Hampshire like Lake Winnipesaukee
um they they might qualify like
Winnipesaukee Association may qualify
for a grant to let's say do mitigation
around
State Park which suffered I think two or
three blooms last summer they were
closed so um
and but it can also be used in um to
support education and communication
because many people that are impacted by
cyanobacteria blooms are on private
property their Waterfront we don't how
do they know
um I know in my experience there have
been people who've been renting
waterfront property spending thousands
of dollars to spend a week Lakeside and
find out they can't go in the water that
they're you know that it's hazardous I
have known people who who a dog died
from going in the water
um so we have the immediate economic
issues but they're also long-term Health
impacts
um and some of the diseases that are
linked to exposures to cyanotoxins are
very they're very horrible diseases and
very expensive ALS
Alzheimer's Parkinson's disease are have
all been linked to cyanotoxin and there
have been very good studies showing that
connection in fact a professor at
Dartmouth Dr Elijah stommel's been a
today
further questions
I do have a couple myself and and I do
want to rely I mean
um Pat tarpey and Andrea Lamar could
probably give a lot of specific
information about the economic
um the economy that's at risk if we
don't mitigate cyanobacteria blooms
well just an observation about Silver
Lake and Hollis it wasn't safe to swim
in 40 years ago when I was a kid so but
anyway in looking at the fiscal note
Des is a management plan would have had
to be submitted do you know are there
any management plans that anyone has
submitted for funds that may be
available or
um they're very limited federal funds
it's extremely competitive it doesn't
fund eligible programs I think the the
watershed management plans many many
like dozens of lakes in New Hampshire
have and rivers have submitted uh
watershed management plans that have
identified projects
some of these projects have been
submitted to the state for funding and
some have been successful and some have
not because the funding the state
provides really gets channeled in from
those 319 federal funds and I believe
um last year it was about 450 to 500
000.
but some of these projects may involve
building new culverts on private roads
because that's the other thing a lot of
these the runoff is coming from private
roads that are run the around these
water bodies and there aren't any
essentially standards for managing that
that runoff so some of these projects
the projects I've seen are actually
re-engineering these roads so that the
runoff can be captured and not go
directly into the lake it could be
naturally treated before it it goes into
that watershed
now the Department of Environmental
Services has said that they'll have to
develop rules to administer this whole
process which often takes six months to
a year and then they're also pointing
out they need at least three people to
oversee this program
in your
requesting about 25 million dollars in
the next year so is that something where
did that 25 million dollars come from I
guess because you've got a number of
moving Parts your administrative rules
hiring staff
plans that have to be submitted to the
department as far as Watershed plans
I I really based it off of uh modeling
the when the pfas fund got established
and also looking at the um the the 319
uh funding that's done for a lot of
these projects now and that half a
million is not sufficient to cover
everything so it's
I don't want to say it was just a number
that pulled off but it was kind of I
looked at some guidelines of what we
what's worked already in the state and
how how projects like this to address
environmental issues have been funded
and that's where I got that 25 million
so here's one other question from me for
the projects that have gone on so far in
the state to address these plumes you
know how much money has been spent like
how much money a year whether it's
private funds or federal funds or
Association funds has been put towards
trying to control these
uh thank you for the question
representative I I think I'd like to
defer to miss Harvey on that she would
have specific examples and maybe Miss
Loma wrote to
um because their their look they this is
what they deal with every day so
um Lake issues
um so if you don't mind I'd rather I
think they could give you more accurate
information
um because Mine mine's very limited I
don't have a full scope of all the
private and public funded projects uh
before you leave any other questions for
the representative for Merrimack seeing
none thank you okay thank you oh and one
more if you don't mind I'd like to just
add one more thing far about people
being hired to administer this right now
there's only one person in the entire
State that's assigned to the site the
it's called harmful algal program
um and
um and then she reports to the water
biologist for the state Mr Neal so
um there we're adding staff where
there's just really one person now so
thank you
so whomever would like to come up the
and if you could state your name for the
uh t-a-r-p-e-y
president of the Lake Winnipesaukee
Association
so our organization is a 501c3
non-profit
um we've you know our mission is to
protect the water quality and natural
resources of the lake and the Watershed
for the past 12 years
um since I've been in this position
we've been conducting water and
Watershed studies on Lake Winnipesaukee
and because it's so large we do it on
what we call a sub Watershed level so
we've completed six of these watershed
management plans for the lake we have
four left to do
um and with those Watershed studies
we've received 319 money to do those
studies 319 money is not available for
planning anymore it's only for
implementation which is what um
319 is through EPA Clean Water Act and
it's administered by the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
as rep representative wrong said for
implementation or restoration there's
only about 500 000 a year available
um it is very competitive our
organization has been very successful in
getting those grants we've probably
received about 500
000 for for restoration work and we've
received another 500 000 for Action The
Watershed planning work that was done
first
um so with the amount of plans we've
completed to date we've identified over
270 sites in need of mitigation at a
cost of roughly four million dollars
which is very conservative it actually
doesn't cover labor and equipment for
this mitigation our consultants and
Engineers base it on
materials and stuff like that and
usually we have to hire an engineer to
come in and give us a real cost number
so
um representative wrong mentioned the
economic importance of Lake
Winnipesaukee in 2021 we had a policy
brief issued by the Nelson Rockefeller
Center for Public Policy and social
sciences out of Dartmouth College to
estimate the value Lake Winnipesaukee
brings to Lakes Region and New Hampshire
and it came in at a little over 17
billion dollars which was kind of an
eye-opener for us but um 16 billion of
that is in property values alone around
the lake another 445 million comes from
revenue from tourism boating fishing and
summer camps
and that 445 million really only
probably represents a fraction of the
two true recreational value the 16
billion in property values brings in
over 200 million in tax revenue for
those shortfront communities
they've definitely recognized the
importance of Lake Winnipesaukee for
them it's their Golden Goose and they're
very much
committed I would say almost entirely
Lake wide to protecting that Lake and
investing money
so when I said we had 500 000 in grant
money that's been matched with another
500 000 from the towns so they're
they're putting money back in for these
projects
um
in the last five years we have seen an
increase in cyanobacteria
occurrences and I have to say honestly I
don't know if it's because it's more
awareness and so people are reporting it
more but we know in 2018 there was only
one advisory issued and last summer
there were 18 observations three alerts
and four advisories
so it's it's increased quite a bit and
maybe it's all with our knowledge and
awareness of it
we do know that the lake from the water
and Watershed studies that our
organization has conducted we know that
the stormwater runoff the amount of
nutrient loading coming into the lake is
300 percent higher than natural
background levels so it's all from
development and that is you know
polluted stormwater runoff accounts for
85 to 90 of our pollution problems
you can look to our neighboring state
Vermont and Lake Champlain what's been
going on there
they
um right now they have property values
have declined by over 15 percent on
Shore front properties they are under
EPA mandate right now to clean up the
lake due to cyanobacteria at an
estimated cost of about one billion
dollars and they're looking at a time
frame of 20 years to do that so 50
million a year and they're wondering
where that money is coming from
so restoration is expensive
um like I said we've identified we
haven't even come close to identifying
all the potential projects and we know
we have a conservative 4 million needed
so the 25 million I think is a pretty
good start
um
you know we're one of many organizations
competing for the limited Federal monies
we do partner with the municipalities
for local cash match and in-kind and
they've been very good about providing
that this loan or grant program would
desperately provide some needed funding
Statewide and to Pro you know protect
our valuable water resources and the
economic importance that our Lakes bring
so that's what I have would you accept
any questions sure representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman if this
money were loaned to you 4 million do
you have the ability to pay it back and
what's your source of income
so as a non-profit yeah we're not
looking for loans but the municipalities
that we work with might take that route
we rely on grants membership donations
that's where we get our funding right
now I'm working with the town of
wolfborough who applied for a loan
through the Clean Water State revolving
fund to do a management plan for
Wolfeboro Bay and it was a hundred
thousand dollar loan they were willing
to do that and it got converted to a
grant so right now what's what's your
general
um
annual revenue or annual expenditures
um right now I've been working on our
budget so four hundred thousand but
that's not covering all matching
representative thank you thank you thank
you for coming
um
what's your impression of the land use
regulations around the lake and how they
affect what's going on I mean are there
Shoreland setbacks there I know there's
been incredible amount of development
has that been
must be contributing to the problem I
just wondered how much effort has been
put into land use right so you know
Winnipesaukee and I'm sure a lot of
communities in New Hampshire
um
it's a different animal sometimes I say
you know you have different levels of
technical financial resources available
based on community you can have a
community that has uh Center Harbor does
not have a professional planner
but you know Noah does tuft and borrow
but Wolfeboro Alton Guilford Laconia
they do so they have planning staff
others don't we don't have uniform
setbacks by community so we're looking
at a watershed Focus but every Community
has different zoning and ordinances for
land use it's something our organization
is looks at in these watershed
management plans we look at what's on
the books now and how we can work with
communities to improve those regulations
they already have
but the other issue is enforcement it's
on the mitigation sites you've
identified are those private properties
or are they Municipal there it's all
it's all public because when we do these
plans we cannot go on private property
yep
so as a follow-up to representative
Evil's question I've spent time up there
in Winnipesaukee and win a Squam and
Squam and over the years has been
greater as she mentioned development
people cut the trees right down the
water level they've got beautiful Lawns
right to the water level which they are
fertilizing adding to nitrogen and
phosphorus in the water so what's being
done to try to address this before it
becomes a problem like do you have a
group that goes around and meets with
landowners or do you put out information
so people know they should have a
generally a better setback instead of
going right to the water's edge or yes
we do
we try and working out not not great
um
we try and work with landscapers to
educate them last summer we started a
program working with all the local
hardware stores about not caring
phosphorus containing fertilizer
um
you know the shorefront protection act
is supposed to restrict that type of
activity but it happens all the time
there are violations and we are actually
have partnered with New Hampshire Lakes
which Andrea behind me can speak to on
the their Lake smart program which is to
work with individual residential
property owners on what they can do on
good afternoon I'm Andrea lamoreaux from
New Hampshire Lakes I can spell my last
name uh L-A capital m o r e a u x
so I'm the president of New Hampshire
Lakes
um and uh representative wrong in patch
harpy from lwa have already done a great
job
explaining the problem explaining the
proposed solution and so I just wanted
to take just a few minutes to just
provide a little bit more data and
another example of a watershed group so
we are supporting this bill and urge you
to support it as you've heard
cyanobacterial blooms are increasing in
New Hampshire in frequency and duration
and just a little bit of data 2022 was
unfortunately a record-breaking year for
toxic blooms in our Lakes the Department
of Environmental Services issued 46
advisories on 36
lakes and rivers so it's not just a lake
problem anymore we're seeing this in our
Rivers
um these advisories accounted for 77
days at our state park freshwater
beaches where people were basically told
to stay out of the water at our state
parks so our citizens and our visitors
were you know told not to go in the
water
Statewide our lakes ponds and rivers
last summer were under advisories for a
total of 829 days
so that's a bummer if the lake
um you know your the water body that
you're you live along or that you're
visiting for the summer is you're told
to stay out of the water the average
length of a bloom last summer was 25
days the longest Bloom was 103 days so
14 weeks essentially the whole summer so
just you know adding to what you've
already heard this is a severe problem a
growing problem a recreational problem
an economic problem
and I just wanted to give you a little
bit more information about the grant
funding that is available currently and
Pat and her team at the Lake
Winnipesaukee Association have done a
tremendous job over the years securing
local funding Partnerships and federal
funding through that 319 program to do
really an amazing amount of work along
around Winnipesaukee
I wanted to just show another example of
a Lake Association Tucker pond in
Salisbury New Hampshire
um small pot has anyone ever been there
it's kind of small Out of the Woods out
in the woods water body but in 2020
Summer of 2020 it started blooming with
a toxic Bloom and it bloomed all summer
and into the fall so basically that
whole summer people couldn't use the
lake the next two years it also bloomed
similarly
and so the residents around that Lake
got together formed a volunteer
cyanobacteria advisory committee they
did fundraisers they got Municipal
support and funding they hired a
consultant and developed a state
approved watershed management plan
so now that they had this plan a lot of
Blood Sweat and Tears they then applied
to Des for the 319 grant program last
fall and while they were told
they had an excellent proposal they did
not re make the cut for being funded the
funding they didn't have enough funding
funding to go low enough and just to get
and give you an idea about what that
group was proposing they were proposing
basically a 10-year action plan that
would cost in today's dollars about 750
000 to address the primary contributors
to pollution to the pond to these
causing these blooms
so there is definitely a need to get
more funding into the hands of groups
who know where the problems are more
quickly
so that we can try to stop these blooms
before we see you know property values
severely plummet more people decide not
to vacation in New Hampshire you know
more businesses losing out on money you
know not being able to have run their
Beach or rent out their boats
so I just added a little more data there
are there any questions yes
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here so you
mentioned stopping the major sources of
pollution to the pond in the case of the
Tucker pond in Salisbury what were the
sources of pollution thank you for the
question great question
um so the sources to their management
plan that they did with their consultant
determined a number of things in a
private septic systems but also a lot of
roadway issues Culvert issues runoff
issues that the town will hopefully be
able to help be a partner in to help
correct but it was a lot of septic and
roadway issues there
follow-up So when you say roadways the
construction of the roadway or is it the
salting the construction basically you
know when we laid out all of our roads
however when we didn't know it wasn't a
good idea to put them right around the
lake and we didn't know better to like
not divert them you know so now it's
reconstructing those roadways we can't
really move them away from the lake but
you know regrading them re-tilting you
know putting more drainage around them
so that water can soak into the ground
and not you know wash off the all the
soil on someone's property and into the
lake thank you
thank you
any further questions representative
evil
what's your sense of the health of
septic systems around our Lakes
because they're big contributors I
assume yes
um my pers my opinion our opinion New
Hampshire lakes's opinion is that
the health of private septic systems
around our Lakes is not good actually
the reason I know this is Pat referred
to is that we run a lake friendly Lake
smart Lake friendly Living Program we've
met with nearly 500 Property Owners at
130 water bodies over the past three or
four years and we go to their house free
service and talk to them how about how
they can become more like friendly and
if they're like friendly we give them an
award and say hey you're like smart we
try to start this this
um
sort of Norm or Tradition at Lakes for
people to live in a lake-friendly way
more often than not we are unable to
give someone a like smart award because
they have a septic system that's
um hasn't been inspected or they don't
know where it is or it's just old and
needs to be upgraded
and so when I testified earlier to the r
d committee you know one of my
suggestions is this may be this Loan
Fund could possibly be something to help
Property Owners upgrade their septic
systems you know we meet a lot of
families that say oh how much does that
cost we can't possibly afford it there's
this misconception that everyone that
lives around a lake you know can afford
whatever and that's not always true so
long-winded answer to your question I
think there's a lot of room for
improvement to improve our Lakeside
septic systems and homeowners need help
representative Kimbrell's
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question we talked earlier about
treatment of these algae blooms how many
treatments did you actually do last year
and at what cost
so once are you asked thank you for the
questions you're asking once a bloom
occurs in a lake what's the manage
management to stop it
yes I think that'd be important for the
committee to know because I know that
I'm on the association on my pond and uh
we just we alert it we note it and then
we let it let it die out right so right
now that's really the only tool there
are no tools in the toolbox really right
now once a cyanobacteria bloom occurs we
have to let nature run its course and
let it naturally die off that can be a
few days that can be several months
so the State Department of Environmental
Services and representative rung
mentioned this they worked on upon nippo
Lake in Barrington on an in-lake
treatment so putting in aluminum a
compound to bind the sediment this that
this fund could potentially get that
those type of tools more readily used
right they hadn't done a treatment like
that for 30 years so two summers ago was
the first time I'd been done in 30 years
so that is something that this fund
see no further questions I believe
representative McGuire has a motion I'll
ask one question before I made motion if
you don't mind
um
is this something that if we allocate 25
million the problem is solved and and
will never have any more or is this an
ongoing thing for the rest of time
that is an excellent question thank you
um
I I think we can realistically say it's
not going to completely solve the
problem forever
um it is certainly going to give us sort
of the the jump start that we need to
start making it much less of a problem
um right now we're just basically
sitting back and and just letting it
happen and we're really can't do
anything about it thank you so I'm going
to make the motion to retain
Saga all right and I I'd like to speak
just a briefly absolutely so the main
problem with this bill is the funding
mechanism is is not normal for us this
borrows 25 million dollars so this
committee doesn't borrow money we spend
it right but we tax it we spend it but
we don't borrow it that's the Public
Works committee and then it's taking
this borrowed money in a lot of cases
using it for Grants so in a sense we're
doing we're we're spending borrowed
money on operating expenses right so
this isn't very good either so
um we're going to have to if we want to
put money in this and and we're pretty
tight this this budget so we're going to
have trouble coming up with kind of
money out of operating expenses so
anyways so I'm I I think we should
retain it and but have to think very
hard on how we're going to pay for this
okay the emotions been made to retain it
was seconded by a representative Hewitt
saying it's just a retain motion show of
hands if we're okay with that
that's unanimous thanks for your
participation all
so next moving right along House Bill
oh yeah
would you
step out for a minute but Mr Hoffman
well
she is out could you give us a little
history
thanks yes the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee
reported this bill ought to pass with a
vote of 20-0 and it passed by a Voice
so 504 is in that packet that you got
today so one that we haven't heard
before
so I'll be with you in just a second
okay
all right welcome to division one
and if you could state your name for the
record thank you my name is Roger
Phillips
p-h-i-l-l-i-p-s and I am chairman of the
Adult Parole Board I have served in that
capacity for approximately nine months
so this is my first time through a
budget
type of session I've practiced Lauren
and Concord for in excess of 50 years
and and have been on the pro board since
2019.
um
the the first part of the the bill would
create the ability for the chairperson
to call on people who had previously
served on the parole board to fill a
spot
in the event that there are was a
hearing day in which we couldn't have
three members available to sit by way of
of background the parole board sits on
revocation
matters on Tuesdays of every of most
every week and parole
granting on on Thursdays and it's a
three-person panel and there are five
members of The Adult Parole Board
two of whom are attorneys one with law
enforcement or Correctional Experience
One in criminology experience who might
be a teacher or whatnot in a
post-secondary school and one of what we
call General and what we're kind enough
or lucky enough I think we have a
retired surgeon who sits in that
capacity so
we um there are times when we can't find
three Pro board members who are
available uh for instance in April uh
what I was trying to do the schedule
there were two days where I could find
two people that weren't going to be in
that would be in state but uh couldn't
find the the third and so that would
allow us to to call on someone who had
previously served
that almost like the same thing we do in
in courts you know whether with a
retired uh justice or or judge to be
able to to come back and and serve for a
day and that we thought would be
appropriate to have a fifteen hundred
dollar uh appropriation and three
hundred dollars a day and we didn't
think would happen more than five times
and hopefully that will be the case
the other part is that of the as
chairman of the board I'm a full-time
state employee but the other members are
part-time and initially uh when this was
proposed to go from a nine member to a
five-member board the salary was was
suggested the compensation would be
thirty thousand and during the
legislative process it got down to 20.
um
my problem is that sometimes when
there's a retirement or a person retires
or or especially in the case of trying
to find an attorney who would be willing
to serve but one must have be an active
member of the bar
so that
it's
it took me almost five months to suggest
to find someone would be willing to
put his name before the governor and
Council to be approved
so that
my concern is that and we ought to
attract people who are dedicated to this
job it's not an easy one it takes a lot
of time
to prepare for especially for the parole
hearings I think there are 23 separate
categories
that we we look at in each parole packet
and it in order to to determine whether
that person would be appropriate to what
has gone through the appropriate
programs to be rehabilitated
rehabilitated and to the best of our
ability that we could predict would not
go out and commit another crime and
become a good citizen and sometimes
we're very lucky sometimes unfortunately
that the parole is revoked but with some
folks that revocation turns out to work
out pretty well and they they see the
light and never come back again so
but certainly we want to be
attract people or fully prepared
dedicated and willing to serve and I I
think for each
parole hearing I it's a good 10 to 15
hours of preparation
before we even get to the to that
hearing and of course we have the
statute requires 35 herrings uh
uh for
for parole on 35 4.
um
revocations but we we have generally run
in the 40s each year for both parole and
Pearl revocations
so that's the basic thing is I was
hoping to get the salary increase from
the 20 000 to the thirty thousand so
that we can keep and and attract good
people and there's a vice chair of the
board also we're very lucky to have
right now uh that physician filled with
Missouri retired captain of a sand of
San Quentin as a correctional officer
and
he uh uh it was a big help but both he
and I are the ones who received the
warrants from the ppos the probation and
parole officers and we reviewed them and
then sign them up there's probable cause
for to indicate that there should be an
arrest made so
that's it and I'm not he not only does
that work but there were lots of other
things that come up you know in an
interpretation of of a sentence or what
someone should have been required to do
or whatnot so
that's why we I have proposed that that
budget be another fifty thousand dollars
so I have a quick question for you in
line 16 it says the vice chairperson
shall receive an annual stipend of forty
thousand dollars to be paid an equal
installments I'm I'm curious 40 000 for
the vice chair and then you're going
down a few lines uh
board members except for the chair and
vice chairman Shelby paid an annual
stipend of thirty thousand correct
so on is there what's yeah well so
what's the chair get the the
I'm a client unclassified state employee
uh so it's uh
because I guess it's step G
um
like I've been my my salary uh I think
is eighty nine thousand dollars a year
you know I was just curious because it
had singled out the vice chair and I
didn't see any other references so I
thought it was kind of odd that he was
getting 40 and others may be only
getting 30 but it it's something to be
good
because the additional because the
additional work of it of the vice chair
okay yes
are there any questions uh
um
attorney Phillips tell us about that how
but let's see the the both for parole I
don't know if I have these figures rated
in in front of me
um I didn't I didn't quite I thought I
might be answering some questions I
didn't think there'd be a presentation
today I should have uh
um
looked up a little bit more but
for instance between
2019 and 2022 basic basically we do 45
hearings and the number and that would
be a matter of usually there are 15 to
as many as 20 a day for that I would
prefer 15 but uh so it would be 15 times
the
44 to give you the the number of hearing
days
and the the number of Parolees really it
it differs
um I I have to uh admit you know the
population of the prison 10 years ago
was about 3 000. it has reduced to about
000 now I think last month it was 18.
but if we're looking at the number of
people that are coming in to reduce I
think mostly because of covet
I mean trials weren't being reached and
and
I spoke at the Barb
at the bar meeting last week to a county
attorney in fact more than one who
well I asked that question he said we
couldn't
expect that there will be more people
more trials and more people entering and
people entering the system
um
you know in in 2019 there were about 1
then it was reduced to 840 last year was
891 I expect it's going to be
more that's here
representative Hewitt
I noticed Section 3 of The Bill calls
for the appropriation of 103 thousand
dollars to pay Adult Parole Board uh
provide board members daily compensation
uh
is is there so is there some reason that
well right right now they're receiving
twenty thousand oh okay all right so
that's it that represents the increase
of what it would be to provide it up to
the 30 and the and that would that would
go for for the period ending uh in the
end of this fiscal year and then then it
takes over the bill takes over as far as
the annual salaries after that that's
further questions representative McGuire
um I do have questions but they're not
really of the nature related to the bill
I'm more interested in the the parole
yeah so
do you get good feedback in the sense
that you learn later if you made a good
decision earlier maybe you're too new in
your position
um so that you you can improve your the
well
the
we know that about 50 percent of the
people we parole
receive a a warrant to come back for a
return
so I consider that a failure on that
part
I would think that that 50 percent would
be reduced to about 20 percent if
we didn't have a significant opioid
crisis and drug use Crisis crisis
and and mental health problems so if if
we could address those
issues when people are paroled and the
to make certain they get can continue
treatment
um you know I I recognize that that
in order to get well from the disease of
addiction a person has to want to
and they often don't want to until they
get in touch with the adverse
consequences of their disease
and sometimes that adverse consequence
is continued an incarceration
on the other hand if if we have
excellent treatment programs out there
and by the way people just because they
um for instance if if they're paroled
and they're supposed to go to a
treatment center
and they just leave that doesn't mean
that there are they have Parolees
automatically revoked
the PPO works with that person price had
got that person into another treatment
center I mean there are we have
Alternatives
that are used and before any warrants
issued we require that the PPO indicate
to us all the alternative sets that are
used
um
but I wish I were able to predict human
nature and what someone was going to do
sometimes there are some real surprises
people with very
long criminal histories
who finally see the light and go out and
do well
and we don't hear from again the only
time we get good
idea of that is when a person is within
three years of the end of their maximum
sentence
uh PPO might recommend that that Max be
suspended so that they no longer are
under supervision
and we see that's one indication where I
see people who have done very well uh
uh but I can't say I don't know why one
knows so much better than another I I
wish I could
well you've only seen them very briefly
right yes yeah
um what fraction of requests for parole
are granted
um it's it's large I think
we had
it's close in
in
222 it was 71.3 percent
21 69.5
in
2065.4 and in 2019 68.9
does that indicate that the sentences
are too long
well that's
that's interesting way back when
I was an undergraduate student in
criminology the professor there said a
maximum sentence of more than five years
is
not doing that person a world of good in
other words that at that
they could get the maximum benefit of
Rehabilitation maybe not punishment but
Rehabilitation within five years
you know that was more than 50 years ago
that I hear that I don't know what if
there are any studies to really indicate
with was better
but I have to
you know in my short time I mean I time
of being on the board
I have to admit I'm impressed with the
Department of Corrections doing the
number of programs that has been able to
accomplish especially with with the
staff shortages they've had they're
still able to do and during covert times
I think we had one of the best rates of
the whole nation of not having covert
run through our prison and having people
second die
thank you for your responses and thanks
for what you're doing represent
cambrells thank you Mr chair
um so these other employees are
part-time baked enough full-time
how many hours per year did they would
you say they put in to do their jobs you
mean what we're talking about is board
members the board the three board
members in the vice chair yes how many
hours per year would you say they put in
well we know that they're going to serve
at least one to two days a week
in a hearing at you know 44
times or more it might be uh eight you
know they could serve 80 days you know
okay we don't we really don't times how
many hours per day yeah and uh
revocation hearings start at 8 30 in the
morning
and it depends if people work out an
agreement or not but they usually go to
three uh 2 30 or three in the afternoon
sometimes till five depending upon the
length of the hair the the reason I ask
the question is because
these are Hefty raises 50 in one case
100 raised in another case and you're
talking about part-time jobs that you're
not talking two thousand hours a year
so I don't know any job that gets those
kind of level raises so what you know
what would be your justification for
that well I I hadn't done the statistics
of the time
and I will I wasn't prepared for that
today but if if you're in order to get
prepared for One Parole hearing it's
more than that hearing day
one that often uh
I've spent up to 50 dollars uh just
doing a
um a parole hearing
for that day's hearing
and some are able to do it a little bit
faster but 10 to 15 hours for that and
then if you're also doing revocations so
you're doing that that whole hearing day
which can be seven or eight hours
depending upon what happens and that it
as well as the preparation time
and for parole revocations they take
less time in preparation but more time
for hearings
so uh but in order to to for instance
attracted attorney on a attorney who's
retired who wanted to be of council to a
firm could certainly be making more than
yeah
okay thank you I understand there's a
motion to be made representative Hewitt
I move out to pass on uh House Bill 504
FM second
it's been moved and seconded uh when the
that's all right I was taking many notes
okay
um okay ought to pass motion on hb504 uh
call the roll representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin no
representative Sweeney yes
Representative cambrells no
representative Hewitt yes
and representative leishman
yes
okay
yep seven to two the motion passes seven
to two thank you sir for your attendance
all right thank you very much
representative Hewitt you'll be
responsible for a committee report
somebody here to talk about it I don't
know
see they'll be coming in with
so uh 269 relative to limiting The
Authority of New Hampshire delegates to
policy making conventions whatever it
happens could you give us a little
Mrs Rawlins oh miss Rollins yeah thank
you this was referred to the state
federal relations and Veterans Affair
committee it came out of the committee
with the ought to pass with Amendment
with a vote of 18-0 it then went to the
floor and came off the floor with the
all right thank you very much is there
not determine yes it represents Sweeney
uh Mr chairman I would say looking at
the fiscal note there really doesn't
seem to be a heft to this bill so
uh seeing as the policy was already
largely approved by the house and it
seems more like it's just a policy Bill
than anything else I think I would move
out to pass this is really no impact on
fiscal
issues representative McGuire are you
seconding that no I I'd like to suggest
an amendment
oh well I will second it for discussion
okay thank you so on page two line 20.
so the peoples in this convention and I
don't know if these conventions are ever
but you should know tell us a history
yeah right exactly but these are these
are legislators right
um whenever a contention is held the
there's four men four members from the
house three members from the Senate
right or something like that
um
and so or two mem one from the Senate to
Etc so so these are legislators and
therefore I I would move that we would
get rid of line four there which is I
mean the Roman four on page two line 20.
which is the hundred dollars a day
so you know expense is fine but pay
seems to be not our thing so so the
hundred dollars per day yeah so I would
ask for an amendment to remove lines 20
and 21 on page two
the division okay with that
it represents Sweeney yeah
representative Weiler
I went to uh won some years ago this is
an article 5 convention and we were
doing some rule
um making for that convention because we
didn't have enough people yet to call
the Article 5 convention there were
about I think 18 or 19 states that have
voted for it at the time and and you
need to have
two states I think to agree to call it
and 38th states to approve the actions
so we didn't have 32 states but we we
met I don't remember getting paid a
hundred dollars a day I think I might
have got expenses
it isn't well like I was worried about
it but there was there was a pretty good
sized group of us there
um
most of whom are no longer in the
legislature so it was a while ago
although Senator Innis has come back he
was on that and Gary Daniels and I think
you know blanking out from Northwood up
anyway what was it
Reagan
um
so
it was a worthwhile thing and the whole
purpose of it is to try to control this
runaway spending that's going on in the
in the Congress they've they've gone
sometimes eight and ten years without
passing a budget
I mean this is ridiculous so that was
one of the purposes of of doing this and
the big argument is not only that
the Congress is manipulating it to say
well we haven't had the total number
there really have been more
but if if the words weren't exactly the
same and including the punctuation no no
we don't have enough
and then they stall anyway so
it's really been a fight to try to get
this article 5 convention and everybody
talks about a runaway convention
and that's not possible all you need is
13 states to say no
and whatever they did doesn't pass and I
can easily think of 13 states that would
not allow some crazy stuff to go
but
anyway it's even going to be hard to get
38 states to say you've got to balance
the budget
because we know
half a dozen that never do
so anyway
the latitude representative we're ahead
of schedule so yeah understood but I
think it's a worthwhile thing to do and
I hope we uh we pass this
all right so looking at the fiscal note
it would appear
that if you go to page it's the last
page another fiscal note
that already members are entitled to 98
daily for lodging and 59 for meals with
adding the hundred dollar payment that
representative McGuire would like to
delete
if that isn't deleted the delegates
would get 257 dollars
day
so there is a
motion just for clarity the motion was
made in I think seconded yes by you yeah
I made for discussion
this is it a separate boat to have the
amendment it would be a separate photo
yeah
this
procedurally if I withdrew my motion can
we make the amendment and then do
another well we could vote on the
amendment if you withdraw sure I'll
on page two
line 20 and 21. yeah but 21. you
originally said you were considered
today right he wants to withdraw that oh
I see what you're saying yes
and I'm sorry so Shelby
um
really I guess my amendment is just
remove the words paid a hundred dollars
per day right and so
you're right thank you for pointing that
right shall be reimbursed for actual
experience oh second then yeah okay what
right now right so we're removing the
words paid through the word in 20 and
20.
157.
yeah I believe so well no I don't think
this is a brand new chapter it's adding
chapter 20-c so
I think it's all new the greatness of
the whole thing was to say if we send
you to the convention you are selected
as the thing here's what you're going to
do you're going to make them pass a
balanced budget and have Fair elections
that's it
so if some if if somebody in our group
decides you know I think we need to do
more than that I think we need to make
this and that now wait a minute you're
recalled
because that's what this is for we told
you we told you the two things you were
yeah
well we've passed this before and then I
think it's either
been
removed or outdated or something but I
remember it we passed this before
see I've traveled to ncsl events and so
forth and I've always rejected any
compensation but legislators are
entitled to compensation
we don't get much either but
so representative McGuire are we clear
on your yes or the amendment is on line
20. remove the words paid 100 per day
and
okay
so it's been moved and it was seconded
by representative Griffin
um
representative Hewitt
it I don't see I'm I'm reading it as I
go along but I I don't see
where in this bill there's any
suggestion of of
what an unauthorized
motion is
what page are you on I'm looking at the
whole the whole thing the definition of
a delegate an interstate convention uh
says that there's been there'll be a
convention but it doesn't say when I
heard I heard Representatives while I
say that it would be prevent you from
not
but not yet not voting for a balanced
budget or something like that I don't
see anything in here that says what you
can and can't vote for and I may just be
missing it
uh representative Sweeney I see it it
just talks about unauthorized amendments
you represent a Sweeney followed by
representative Weiler no just jumping
off of what we're up there while they
were saying uh the permitted scope means
the topic or of an amendment or specific
language of amendment that may or
proposal that may be considered By Any
Given Interstate or Interstate can mean
body uh in which the numerous states are
represent I think the the authorized
State scope is set in the resolutions
that would pass to form the Article 5
convention separate from this and this
is just saying that the delegates from
New Hampshire are not authorized to move
or support any unauthorized so it's in
the separate resolutions that the states
would pass to form the Article Five
is what the authorized scope is and
isn't in this case and not in this bill
and this bill just binds the delegates
to whatever that authorized scope is
regardless of what the issue that led to
the convention
and then on page two line 24.
yeah my question is what is an
it's
this just has a structure
this creates a structure for if you're
going to a convention here's who goes
here's what they're paid Etc right
correct here's what they do but to
create to send people to a convention
you need a separate resolution like like
last week we failed uh HCR one right
that would have sent people to a to a
convention and in HCR one it said this
is a convention to balance the budget or
something like that right to control
suspended so so it's not in here because
you could have a resolution to you know
add a second vice president or something
right
and Roman two on that page also yeah
so we'll just have a show a hands on the
McGuire Amendment
all right so you would like to offer
thank you
get a set language
LBA as far as the removal of the 100.
but
okay we'll uh vote with the
understanding that the LBA will get us
the amendment we'll take a look at that
but we'll have a vote we'll trust you
with this one representative McGuire
so all in favor will say I when the
clerk calls your name okay
however you cared about okay uh
representative McGuire aye
aye
representative Kim browse
aye representative Wallner
no
representative Hewitt oh
oops wait a minute
um clerk votes eye
now what would I just
oh and representative Weiler
aye
all right so we're right on time here
[Laughter]
yeah
so we'll open the work session on 250 FN
relative to accidental death benefits
payable to a group 2 member
representative baroody I saw you hiding
someone oh there you are hiding behind
so before you speak represent Broody Mr
Hoffman or Melissa a little history
docket
sure so this bill HB 250 went to Edna
came out of Eda with ought to pass 15 to
5 with the minority committee report
being an expedient to legislate and then
it went to the house
ought to pass with a roll call of 260 to
103.
thanks very much representative perrotti
I used to see you represented peruty for
those of you who don't know it was my
vice chairman for a term
two terms we had to put labels on the
anyway well thank you Mr chairman nice
to be back in division one again
um this is um
this is something we fell upon a few
years back
um
this is a death benefit for police and
fire who get killed in a line of duty
um you know they're out protecting us
our families our property and if they
get killed in a line of duty
dispose only gets half of their
retirement
they could go
skydiving and get killed and
their family would get their full
retirement so it doesn't really make
sense that they're working for us
they get killed
and the spouse only gets half and the
family only gets half
and a lot of times you know the people
that are the younger people that are the
ones that are In Harm's Way more than
the older people sitting behind a desk
so
a young family
um
really needs every everything they can
get
and this is just a fairness thing and uh
are there any questions for
representative representative thank you
Mr chair yes it says accidental death it
doesn't say anywhere here on the job
would it also if they just died in a
skiing accident
I don't see anywhere it says accidental
death doesn't say on the job anywhere as
far as I can I can tell again I have
nothing against the bill but that is a
big distinction I don't remember how it
reads but it's um
it is in the line of duty if they get
killed in a line of Duties when they get
penalized agreed but that's not what the
bill says
the bill says accidental death
uh if if anyone wishes to speak if you
could just grab the mics come on up
yeah like I said I don't remember it
we'll hear it we'll hear from the
representative from the state retirement
system thank you
Mark Cavanaugh associate Council
compliance officer accidental death is
our term of art for work related death
under our statute under RSA 100 a it's
called accidental versus ordinary which
is a non-work related death
appreciate that clarification
further questions for representative
baroody represent Maguire thank you very
much thank you representative I I guess
I don't understand what you mean I think
you're you're conflating retirement pay
retirement benefit and compensation
because what this is is 50 of
compensation what your current salary is
Right versus you said they get if
someone died just from any other cause
they would get a hundred percent of
retirement benefits which is a different
number correct no it's it's I believe
it's the same it's their benefit that
they get
at the time of their death
either an accidental death or an
ordinary death if it's an accidental
death which I said is in the line of
so so there must be another a different
section that covers the other 100 yes
yeah yeah it does
could you give us let's just pulled out
the section that we thought was wrong
which was the accidental death which is
you were recently given a brief by the
retirement system it's got some
clarifying language for the death
benefits
representative Hewitt
yeah this is similar to the previous
compensation average final compensation
is a term about used by the retirement
system uh
and that's how that's how it's
it's a total compensation it's sort of
like saying that it was accidental death
that's not a that's not a term of Art
and if you say our accidental death the
retirement system won't be obligated to
pay anything likewise the what they
calculate the amount
by average compensation
and not average salary
I've got that right
so uh
under our statute there are two death
benefits ordinary not work related
accidental work related
um
in order to qualify for the ordinary
the benefit is
50 percent
of the retirement Service retirement the
member would have been eligible for at
that time so for instance very young
they might not have been eligible for
anything
accidental
is
for group twos currently 50 percent
of their annual earnable compensation
which we count as what was paid the last
12 months not a three-year average not a
five-year average
accidental is paid regardless of years
of service and it's also tax-free
ordinary disability death benefits are
taxable
and it's a lower benefit and if the
member who's passing away hasn't yet
qualified
Forest Service retirement because
they're only 40
well well group twos you know they
haven't reached that age there's no
early retirement for group twos so under
ordinary death it's it's a a much lower
benefit Than The Accidental
and know what this bill is proposing to
do is they take it from 50 of annual
compensation to 100 and just to draw a
contrast the group one accidental
benefit on the job death is
it's uh 50 of final average compensation
so that is three and five years so this
there's a difference between the two
this one's slightly more not very much
depending on how the averages are but
those are the distinctions between
section 88 and section 89. are there any
group ones who are earning this who who
died
you know mostly Dot
people who got hurt in car truck
accidents and working you know people in
the more hazardous positions they're a
few scattered around
there's more
I believe there's more I'm going to say
there's more there's a higher percentage
and a much higher likelihood
in group two
there may be more in group one because
it's a much bigger group
but it's not it's not a lot issue to see
on the back of the
Bill brief I believe there's only 19
people collecting this benefit in group
two right now
brother but yes now would the cost of
this bill go on the the employers
whether they be state or Municipal yes
and that's on the second page the back
page of the bill brief it shows
what the what the impact would be
on the contributions as well as the
underfunding
uh it's
larger for political Subs in the States
because that's a much bigger group
um but it's a relatively
okay not a huge number 19 million I
think okay and one more question so how
do we know the specific number this 2026
number of 320
000 is that because there's a certain
number of people in this yes we took to
people who actually collecting the
benefits and made some projections as to
what new people might be collecting and
what they're you know based on the
frequency of the current population is
Actuarial assumptions okay so this is
just a guess right right they're
projecting based on past experience this
is how many people will collect abundant
and benefit in the future and then
you're taking all inflation increases in
compensation and the increase in the
benefit and say Here's what those future
benefits will cost
and that's what the increase you know
the compare it to current law and new
law can ask representative
yes so representative Brewery
is there any what's what justifies
um giving this benefit not to group one
you know we were looking at the group
tools are like four or five years ago
and found this unit and I don't know
what would one gets he says it looks
like it's the same
yeah so
um I don't think too many people in
group one get
fatally injured for one thing I mean he
mentioned
well dot is one but I I mean also you're
covering police will carry guns and
shoot at people and people shoot back at
them and firefighters will go into
burning buildings and you know the
saving
you know they respond to everything uh
accidents and drug related stuff I mean
they get a rotten job
they got a real rotten job I don't know
anybody in group two any any firefighter
or police officer that gets up and says
I'm going to have a nice day at work
today they have no chance they just
don't have a chance thank you
represent Griffin followed by
representative Weiler I mean I I guess
my questions for the retirement system
and I'm I'm trying to grasp this and
understand it
so let's say I'm a Class 2 employee I
have 10 years of service I'm working as
a fireman
I'm climbing up a building in the middle
of a fire I fall off the ladder and I
get killed
right
what's my benefit
well your spouse would get happier
the representative from the retirement
system an opportunity to come up to
answer that question yeah but I think
that what it is you're lying
so I'll repeat the question and I'm a
firefighter 10 years on the job I go to
a fire I fall off a ladder I get killed
what's my benefit do I get is is this
bill give me half my current salary or
this bill would increase it from 50 to
100 to yourself
of your final years annual uh average
I'm not sorry your final years earnable
compensation whatever is reported to us
in the 12 months prior to your death
okay so basically what this Bill is
saying is if a group two employee has
dies on the job
job related right he gets half his
annuals I mean he gets a hundred percent
of his annual salary right it's taking
current law and changing the benefit
from 50 to 100 and how long does that go
on
so until you guys decide to change it
again until you guys decide to change it
again no I mean how long oh for the rest
of her life um for the rest of her life
the surviving spouse and if there is no
surviving spouse or the spouse dies and
there are still children under 18.
children under 18 and there's even an
outlier that's never really happened if
there was no spouse and no children but
there were dependent parents they would
get the annuity I don't think that's
ever actually happened but it's in the
statute and just to clarify one thing
you said you you mentioned 10 years of
service you don't need any
could be one day yeah
okay so so it just continues the salary
as long as the spouses surviving
children are alive well the difference
being that there'd be no income tax on
it the salary is taxed no X is not the
benefit is not I have one other question
if I die in the job what other benefits
do I get is there a lump sum
there is a state statute we do not
administer for First Responders that has
a death benefit I believe it's a hundred
thousand it has to be recommended by
um
by the the person who uh their boss or
whoever I think it's just state
employees it has to be approved by the
executive Council I think that's just
state employees that's not our benefit
there's also a federal benefit I'm not
very familiar with it but the maximum
benefits for over 400 000 but there's a
lot of rules there so I don't want to
opine on that I don't think anybody sure
yeah it's more paper than real I think I
don't think anybody in New Hampshire is
on that yeah representative Griffin's
gonna follow up yeah
um
well I'll hold it maybe it'll get
answered
representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman
a couple of decades ago representative
Bernie ronowska was retired firemen
he gave up part of his pension to have a
survivor's Benefit Plan
then his wife died before him
he didn't get any money back and then we
had a few a few years later firemen came
in and said oh nobody can afford to give
up that for the survivor's benefit plan
we should get it without giving up
anything and that was decided to do that
that was a gift it was also part of the
problem that we're now 5.7 billion in
the hole in the retirement system this
would make it a bigger hole and we we
see these all the time when nobody's
thinking ahead what can we do about the
debt and the retirement system I don't
want it to go bankrupt so everybody gets
a fraction of what they think they're
going to get but all these things you
bring in
are going to make the whole bigger
that's my feeling
representative Griffin has a question
okay one one final one does this employ
does this
apply only to State Employees or does it
lie to Municipal Employees also
if the state retirement system this is
the retirement system covers all public
employees
with one exception there are some
people in Manchester will have their own
plan non-police non-fire non-teachers
have their own planual secretaries
administrators
dpws everyone else if you work for the
government you're in our plan this would
cover group twos police and fire at both
the political subdivision level and the
state level which is State Police
forestry and a few other agencies where
there are certified police officers so
would 21A
apply to this
you can't interpret someone else's life
unfunded mandates from the state
um
can't a pine on that
a resident expert from the old Edna
committee
no I just I believe the way the courts
have
um have interpreted 28a is that if it's
an if it's a change of type in an
ongoing expense you know like like this
one is it's okay if it's a brand new
expense you know we just we we
require nursery school or something then
that would be a 28-day violation if you
see what I mean but a change a detail
change and something that's sort of
ongoing is not so I think that's the way
they interpreted
thank you representative McGuire
representative yeah
um addressed something that was said
earlier
I think it was back in the 90s and I
can't remember what year when the
retirement system was really robust
there was a lot of money in the system
the state we took a lot of money out of
that system
to help balance our budget and I'm not
sure what year that was maybe somebody
else would know I'll speak that was a
and we never recovered from that
well that was never
um you're not allowed to do that the
money's in of trust for the exclusive
benefit and it would be a violation
fiduciary duty federal law and our state
constitution to use the money for
anything other than the benefits
of for the members in the beneficiaries
so I know way back we did take some Cola
money out which was to benefit the
beneficials you used money in our
account to pay a cola to increase
pensions for our members so it was for
their benefit had a secondary benefit of
not costing the state anything to pay
for the cola but it was using planned
funds to increase the benefit of plan
members so that is legal right
okay representative Sweeney
so Mr chairman at this time looking at
this bill knowing the history with it's
a policy that has passed the house and
was supported by a sizable margin there
uh knowing that we have other bills that
we're dealing with that tackles parts of
the unfunded liability uh and this is
really a key discussion in the budget I
I think we should retain this
legislation uh continue the conversation
on what we're doing with the retirement
system at large but we have a lot of
moving pieces here so I would make the
motion to retain
the moisture has been made by
representative Sweeney second by
representative
camberells is there any more discussion
seeing none since it's a retained motion
just a show of hands if everyone's okay
with that
it's unanimous thanks
foreign
the work session on House Bill 4th 36
relative to group 2 retirement under
transition Provisions in the retirement
system
is that representative Pratt standing up
back there
welcome to take this Melissa
and uh Melissa you have the docket for
us how this is made it this far I sure
do
passed with Amendment 16-3 with the
Minority Report being inexpedient to
legislate it then went to the house
floor with ought to pass with Amendment
thanks Melissa
representative Pratt how are you good
that takes care of my first line I was
it came out very strongly
um this bill is a retirement Bill a lot
of you here know the history of this it
goes back to fixing some of the changes
that were made in 2011.
it uh
further spreads out the chart which
we'll explain later on
instead of being five different levels
it's making it out into a nine different
levels to further spread it out there
will be basically a tier a b and c now
and basically because of the year of
their Style
you have a uh a thing from the New
Hampshire retirement system that
explains the cost of it
or an estimated cost
and it gives you a good background here
in 2011 major changes was made to the
retirement system so it was
retroactively after the people already
hired some of them had been working for
quite a few years at that point up to
nine years and the change the benefits
would change to what they were hired for
I had hired some of those people years
ago I was a fireman for 28 years this
doesn't affect me but it does affect
about eight people I hired
uh so this is a group two firemen
policemen and guide spill uh does a
little bit with group one and basically
because of the cap on their glue point
is included
the average there will be a cap still
remaining on this there was a 5 000 wood
amendment made to the original bill so
uh in that Amendment we came to retained
the cap so there was no way that they
can anybody can make more than 125
percent
that was one of the major concerns back
in 2011 I believe so that's a good cap
and now this doesn't totally restore
everything that was done in 2011. it's
very conservative we went on the
conservative side as far as trying to
draw this up but we're trying to fix
some of those things uh right today I've
heard of three guys that are retiring
today so uh those some of these people
are right at the point that they're
retiring this is very timely it's a
really a good time to be doing this
because uh 2011 and now uh if you have
23 to 24 years and you can retire so
some of these people come and do right
now so
uh it'll do a few things
retention is one of them how the the
date that it starts is a few years out a
couple years out so by doing it a couple
years out we're hoping that will retain
a good number of people that would be
leaving right now they would stay
another one to two years or three years
in order to get the full band of the
better benefit
so um and then as far as uh recruitment
um there was a lot of concerns that the
benefits were changed after a person
could be hired so that scared a lot of
people about coming into a system that
could be changed after they're already
hired so this right here says that no
changes are made for three years after
the Hyatt so that's a little bit of
security and a lot of people feel I
think this will help a lot of people
feel a lot more secure with the system
and not be so concerned about everything
changed and after you've worked nine
years
so it's a little security thing in here
so that's a good thing and that will
also help I think in uh bringing new
people in and I don't have to go into
the numbers but uh we have a lot of
shortages in the fire service right now
how to get people like we used to for 18
years I was commissioner fire standards
in training we used to do uh testing
over there we'd have 300 people come to
a test and now they have like 30 come to
a test so it's um State Police are
advertising on TV they used to have two
or three hundred people waiting to get
into State Police all policemen that
wanted to become State Police and and
now they're advertising on TV to try to
get people so the shortages in all
fields and I I don't know if you heard
any testimony from the gods the gods are
down 40 percent and they're making
people work overtime which is also a big
cost everybody's working overtime lots
of overtime and that's expensive so
so it's a lot of money but it's also
very conservative what we've put
together here Steve can go into the
details Steve has a lot a lot to do this
DPS in from Manchester
and uh so if you get into questions you
well I appreciate your I know we all
appreciate your efforts on this I try to
correct some of the issues back in 2011.
that's a goal
um
I know are there any questions for
representative Pratt
must have done an excellent job oh yes
thanks for your presentation
representative Pearson do you have a
couple of comments
you can sit right up there next to him
again just state your name for the
record please
I'm Representative Steve Pearce in
Rockingham District 13 which encompasses
Dairy I'm an active member of the New
Hampshire Retirement System
this legislation in front of you was a
collaborative effort that involved
um
six different members of the House
in its initial form
and
all of the stakeholders that would be
covered under this
plan
on January 11th I was summoned to the
speaker's office
which frankly should scare the hell out
of you it certainly did to me
um
because I didn't know what I was walking
into
and what I walked into was a request to
fix this problem
and uh representative Carol Maguire
representative Simon both chair and vice
chair of Edna myself
um the leadership team of the house the
Republican caucus of the house uh we're
in the room we went over the problem and
the speaker flat out asked me can I fix
this
and I told him I could because that's
what you tell the speaker when he asks
you a question like that
so it took three weeks of work to come
up with a way to do this that that did
two things one
that it solved for the most part the
damage or repaired the damage that had
been done in 2011 but also did so in a
manner that protected the system of in
and of itself because damaging the
retirement system is not in the best
interest of any of us
whether you're in the system or not
so
a preliminary draft was was uh was
created it was presented
to Edna and Edna Begin work sessions on
the particulars of this
the form that 436 has now is voted on by
the house
was was written by representative Pratt
myself representative Carol McGuire and
representative Simon
that is the language that's in front of
you today
I am
not going to repeat my testimony in
explanation of this in Edna because it
took an hour and 15 minutes
but I can I'm I can certainly go through
it the cliff notes of of this and I'm
more than happy to answer questions
one of the things that happened as we
look at the very beginning on line five
from a 2011 Merrimack Superior Court
lawsuit
was a request by a judge to come up with
a definition of vested because New
Hampshire State Statute
ironically doesn't Define it there's a
presumption that the retirement system
has used for years that the
qualifications of benefit occur at 10
years and the presumption was that's
when you were vested
but there's never actually been a
definition in statute
I don't know why it took us
12 years to come up with this it
shouldn't have honestly should have been
handled at the time but
it's never the wrong time to do the
the the 10 years which is how the
calculations of the pension system are
based right now was was retained despite
the fact that four of the six New
England states and New York vested five
years
this is what the presumption has been
this is what the faction the financials
are based on a 10-year length of service
to qualify for a benefit and we thought
it would be too disruptive to modify
that
now one of the things that was added
here is two specific areas of Statute
that get that can't be reduced after
three years of service and that is just
basically what a year is worth to you
and what they include to figure out how
your retirement is calculated
that was done as a reputation fix
because frankly right now the state of
New Hampshire in the New England area
has an absolutely horrible reputation in
emergency services
it's basically stated that the state of
New Hampshire cannot be trusted
so that was done as a way to try to mend
some of that keep in mind that there are
other things that are not included in
this that can be modified this is just
the two biggest areas that the
stakeholders were most concerned about
in the event that we have a situation
that does warrant modification there are
other elements and again this is statute
it's not constitutional law this can in
the event of a catastrophe there's a lot
of things that could be changed I will
remind a finance committee that the
pension system does have 11 billion
dollars in assets right now
they are we are not in a crisis level by
any stretch of the imagination
it's the highest actual level of
Holdings that the pension system has
that is policy area policy I suppose
number one is the is the part of that
when you get into the next few
paragraphs
what happened was in order to process
this we had to separate group one and
group two in into separate paragraphs
since we were making a change specific
to the way group two is is looked at
versus group one
so what that does is it basically just
splits the groups up in statute instead
of having paragraphs where the two
as an example on the top of page two
lines two and three permanent firemen
and policemen were removed because
they're not in group one
as in subsequently in the in the group
two paragraphs this the areas in
reference to the teachers and the state
uh University system not included
because they're not group two that's
just that's just language cleanup to
make sure that the two groups
definitions are properly defined and
that was run through the New Hampshire
retirement system to make sure that that
the reason line 26 and 27 were removed
from page two was because
in a very bizarre manner the law said
hey
do what's in paragraph 13. well
paragraph 13 already tells you to do
what's in paragraph 13. So it seemed
kind of weird that you would have a
second place to tell you to do something
in another paragraph when that paragraph
already tells you to do it so that was
struck out and has no effect
is in change in any way it's just a
language cleanup
page three covers like I said the change
of splitting group one and group two
into two separate groups
um
that's why it's in bold
is because of the split
when you when you get to page four under
average final compensation the same
thing had to happen group one and group
two had to be split
and that does the same thing
where there may be the appearance of a
policy change page five line item 32
that the line that was struck out was
done because it is impossible
to be vested six months into your career
under
99.9 percent of examples
the pension system was complicated
enough this was just a matter that was
done to make things a little bit simpler
which which is ironic but yeah
on a on a book that has its own
publication
so getting into what the bill does
when we get to page seven as
representative Pratt stated the the
chart the exploding of the chart from
the four categories into nine has no
substantive change all we did was
separate them into one year blocks
instead of two-year blocks or in the
case of less than four years a four-year
block
this was necessary
to separate them into one-year sections
in order to affect an annual change if
we had not done that you would have
groups of people that would be some
would be required to do one thing and
others would be asked to do more this
but the minimum years of service minimum
age and annual multiplier are identical
the when we what's that yep when we get
into page eight one of the one of the
concessions that was that was agreed to
by the stakeholders in order to prevent
a problem that was occurring in the past
was the pension cap was modified
current statute institutes a pension cap
in 2009 that's when it was enacted
so there were some fears that by
putting folks back to the conditions
under which they were hired we would
have a potential for someone to have
what some refer to as a runaway pension
or an excessive pension
to prevent that from occurring the
pension cap
was moved backwards to July 1 of 0-1 so
all the folks that are covered by this
and that way we don't have those
conditions occurring
we those of us that are stewards of this
system
agree that having excessive
what someone would look concerned you
know consider outrageous pensions is
detrimental to the system it doesn't
look good for the public and the system
frankly wasn't set up for it
so that takes that whole concern off the
table
the pension cap currently that was
instituted in 2009 was set at 120 000 if
you took a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in today's value it's 166
thousand three six hundred and thirty
eight dollars
that also would be considered excessive
so rather than put that into today's
dollars
the thought process was that rather than
put in the ability for the cap to adjust
itself annually
now one and a quarter percent is going
to probably never keep up with inflation
but it does at least keep the cap from
being a stagnant dollar
it also allows the retirement system to
have a fixed hard number of a cap to
make projections moving forward
rather than being based on some kind of
tying to some sort of a CPI type of
thing which you see in some other states
this is just a hard number and they
could pick a date out 30 years and say
okay we know what the cap will be at
that is the that is where the one and a
quarter percent comes from you earn two
and a half percent per year of service
the one and a quarter is just like I
said to keep that moving the other thing
is over time if you have a stagnant
number you start to have a ceiling
where 15 years from now let's say
salaries change and and the value of the
dollar changes you don't want to be in a
situation where your pension cap forces
people to leave the longer someone works
in the pension system the better it is
for the system so we don't want to get
in a situation where we tell people hey
you hit the cap see you later
we want to encourage people to work as
to give you an example of that the
average roughly the average group two
pensions and somewhere in the 40 45
we'll use forty five thousand dollars I
suppose is a round number
so for every year you keep someone in
the system that's forty five thousand
dollars they're not withdrawing but
they're putting in portions of their
paycheck so it's a flip
where you're adding to the system and
not withdrawing that is why having
someone work longer is better
as representative Pratt stated
understated we have a substantial labor
problem in group two right now
and as a as a long-standing commissioner
he saw this
from a global standpoint I'll give this
to you from a city of Manchester
standpoint
I tested with 400 people 20 years ago
for nine positions the current hiring
list in the city of Manchester is zero
zero we're taking people from other
municipalities
that if you had told someone 20 years
ago that that would be the case they
would have laughed at you
Corrections has 300 openings at the
state right now
State Police are advertising as far west
as Ohio
because we can't get people
so part of that is a severe credibility
problem with the state of New Hampshire
and we just lost a guy in Manchester
whose folks still live in the city and
he's going to the Carolinas because what
they have to offer down there is stable
so
this will begin the healing process if
you will this does not Institute a new
benefit this does not Institute anything
for anyone that occurred after July 1 of
11.
those folks were hired under the
conditions that they currently are
there's no surprises there nothing
nothing was done retroactively to them
I have a state trooper that had nine
years 11 months and two weeks when this
changes came on
17 days away from from the difference
between you know the article 23 the
State Constitution clarifies and talks
about retroactive lawmaking this is not
rules this is not a private firm this is
statute this is law there's a reason why
the other 48 of the 50 states didn't go
retroactive when they made their changes
between 2010 and 2012. and the 49th
state that did reverse their decision
two years later we are the only state
that went backwards
and we shouldn't have done it
so this does not bring them back a
hundred percent at all like I said
there's another concession I didn't even
touch on is the enaction date because I
guess I didn't get to that point the
inaction date if you look at the very
end of this paragraph 17 that takes
effect staggered annually that is done
to force God the members of group two to
work an additional year
to gain this benefit
that was a trade-off it was a trade-off
the two trade-offs actually come to
around 35 million dollars of value
that's what was shaved off the original
cost of this is roughly 35 million
they have the ability to leave
beforehand
under the current math if they so choose
but we are asking them to give an
additional year of service to help with
this labor problem because with them
leaving I don't have anybody behind them
the as for those of you in Rockingham
County that were at the
last Rockingham County meeting the
department of corrections there had a
report that ranks the Department of
Corrections in the 50 states based on
salary working conditions pension
benefits and and the like they rate
they rate all 50 states New Hampshire
finished dead last we are 50 of 50.
that is not a badge of honor
50 of 50. I I didn't realize that it was
it was to that level but that's that's
what the report said so the corrections
folks
um who are Beyond crisis mode this is a
big deal to them right now
now getting into the
legalese part of this
and the part that gets that made me not
sleep for 22 days was starting in
paragraph six which is page eight page
nine and ten there's more Roman numerals
here than a
than a Roman Historic Site
what that basically does
is that is how this bill amends itself
annually
because as we're asked as because as
we're asking them to give the additional
year we have to implement it
I know it's terrifying looking
but it's it's the same paragraph
repeated nine times just with a date
change
I was assured by OLS that this is not
the only thing that they've ever passed
that had that is self-amending I
they've done it with other things
um and they felt that this the way to do
this prevents this from being a 92-page
bill
is just to do it in a sum up form like
that
so this past the house 282 to 80
despite a speech that was given with an
exorbitantly incorrect fiscal note
so the the house has clearly established
a position of policy on this this is
something that's been looked at for six
years now
and it's time to just end this to fix it
thanks for your work representative
Pearson
representative McGuire question thank
you and thank you representative you
just impugned our LBA in saying that the
fiscal note is incorrect In what way is
it incorrect
did I say that a little bit I'm just uh
the original fiscal right really oh yeah
so uh what happened was we we put in for
uh uh a number to come from the
retirement system and it took a long
time to get it because of all the moving
Parts here so uh it we didn't have a
number going into the meetings we were
having so we took another bill that did
more than this building
549. we use that Bill's number which was
uh 125 million which was 250 million 250
million wait 250 million so we use that
number to uh actually give you an
estimate of what it would cost this
doesn't have as many benefits uh
corrections as that one did that one
actually also included um other people
outside of this group it made no
concessions of any kind no concessions
so we made a lot of concessions in here
and we did a lot of things to pare it
down so that number was a lot higher
than this number so they voted on it
with this higher number with a number it
was a lot higher than what it's actually
going to cost
that that was not a mistake on lba's
part that was that was on the mistake of
a legislative speech
represent Maguire followed by
representative Griffin so does this bill
not spend 25 million dollars of the
general fund for 10 years
it does it does okay so that is 250
million dollars well
and and in addition to that from the
political subdivisions 13 million eight
hundred and sixty thousand I don't know
I'd have to ask if that's a one-time or
a or multiple times so when you
when you do a payment like this the
value of a dollar today is different
than a value of a dollar tomorrow right
so the retirement system takes those
funds and invests those funds
they have to give you a snapshot based
on a presumed rate of return which they
are using at six and three quarter
by their own publication which we all
get the average rate of return for 3 5
10 and 25 years is seven one seven two
eight five and six nine all of which are
higher than the conservative rate of
return they use right now so as this
bill
oh is enacted and moves forward you
would have in two years a re-look at
where you are if you have
a substantially better rate of return
like say we had in 2021 then that cost
would go down and likewise
but with a 3 5 10 and 25 year averages
all above the conservative level here
riding the Peaks and valleys
their estimation of cost is an
overestimate and it should be
it should be but based on empirical data
from from their own publication their
meeting that goal has not been a problem
over that time period
yeah
all right let's let's go on
um
isn't it so so this this bill benefits
only those who are hired in 2011 and
earlier correct from from July 1 of 01
to July 1 of 11. it is a fixed number of
people it cannot be increased it can
only be reduced so those people even
under current law have a superior
pension to people who are hired
subsequent to 2011 is that right it is
because the legislature has the right to
make changes to the pension system
for folks that don't exist yet
okay and the legislature chose to do so
and and I and I will defend that
okay but if the purpose of this is to
improve hiring shouldn't we
give extra benefits to people
who will be hired as opposed to giving
benefits to people who are hired between
2001 and 2011. if if you hire someone
tomorrow that has a benefit that someone
with 15 years on what you will do
socially to group two will be
catastrophic
no but we've already said that the the
15 years on people are better than
today's people because they were hired
under those conditions they knew that
when they took the job
these folks that were retroactively
changed entered the profession under a
different agreement under different
conditions it made their decision for a
career in the state of New Hampshire and
their subsequent financial planning
based on what was presented to them when
they were hired if you were hired July
2nd of of 2011 what you were presented
the day you were hired is identical to
this this is this is fixing the fairness
part of it what you're talking about is
the people that comes after this they're
getting less of a benefit that would
have to be something that would help me
look at at some point if you wanted to
bring those people up to this level
you'd have to convene the decennial
commission it would have to be a
separate a separate thing but I can
understand what you're saying is the
people behind these people are not
getting what these people getting but
they were hired knowing that so that's
why they're not included in this number
there'd have to be another look at to do
that group of people after before these
people people came in after these people
understand that's what I mean I think
yeah
representative Griffin please
so uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking the question
so in the last biennium
we also had a bill addressing the same
High School 1587 in the last bienna
addressed a portion of of this right so
it was a part of it in in that
um that fix in the appropriation that
was done
um to that
so I guess my question is
I don't want to say Final Solution
there's some bad
connotations to that but is is this the
the final bill we see on this particular
problem the the speaker was very clear
to me when he when he said to fix it so
fixing it means all the way and this is
like I said with with this the
stakeholders involved with the folks
that
that needed to be at the table this this
is considered the fix
after the if this is implemented it's
done
for other questions representative
Weiler
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Pearson and
representative
and
2011.
we had a two billion dollar hole
in the retirement system they attempted
to fix it
virtually everything they tried has been
undone since so now we have a 5.7
billion dollar hole what does this do to
the percentage of unfunded liability of
the pension system is far better now
than it was then the pl we're at 66
percent
sure we are we have 11 billion over 11
billion in assets right now which is the
highest it's ever been
the problem here is not to address the
fix but it also does not touch upon what
the decennial commission put forward
with the plan to repair the unfunded
liability which has now been enacted 11
years and is working successfully
my assessment of what you've done makes
that hole bigger
because you're increasing everybody's
compensation
you're increasing the contribution by
the employer but not by the employee
I think pain should be shared equally so
the
employees contribution rate was
increased in 2011 from 9-3 to almost 12.
right with a reduction in benefit
if you had done that increase and left
things alone and grandfathered everybody
I still think there would be folks that
would have an issue with that but it
went the other way all this does is say
yes you you did require an increase
in employer rates employee rates excuse
me
but then you also went and reduced the
benefit at the same time so
that
though frankly those folks have been
paying for the last 10 years
they've already they've been asked to
know have been doing it for a decade so
have you reduced the contribution rate
for by the employee no not at all
and by rights the argument could be made
to do so but again we felt that that
would not be beneficial to the system
overall to make a reduction so that was
left alone
the only way you're going to get into
this 5.7 billion dollar hole is if
everybody pays more obviously this is
this is going to increase the
compensation for the members but I think
it's going to make a bigger hole in the
5.7 billion
so keep in mind that this is not
instituting a new benefit to anybody
this is restoring 95 percent of the
benefits they had already
so you can't you can't go down the
street and steal my bike and bring it
back two weeks later and then ask me to
pay for it
right
so I understand that so that that's
that's in essence the the
oversimplification of this
the
also too
for the most part minus a little bit of
wiggling
in the in the back with this with a
differential of 13 million which may or
may not exist as this moves forward
based on investment returns
the this does not increase the debt
because it's being pre-funded by the
general fund
if this was dumped directly into the
debt I would agree with you that it
would be increasing the debt the overall
debt follow-up follow-up What
specifically did the speaker ask you to
fix
it
[Music]
to me that's the 5.7 billion hole that
is not what we talked about in that room
what was discussed in that room was
bankruptcy of the whole system at 11 and
a half billion dollars of assets I find
that very very seven billion dollar hole
sure
we are we are at 66 funded we rank 13th
in the country
so why we're not I don't think we're I
don't think we're at death's door here
so I I had a couple of questions if
there are no further questions from the
division thus far
how many people would be affected by
this like
1572 1572.
so I think there's some important
language on the document that the
retirement system gave us if we don't
fund this 25 million dollar
appropriation that is
if the appropriation is not paid the
employer's contribution rate for police
and firewood increase significantly
and the expected increase in the
unfunded liability would be 203 million
dollars so correct going forward if we
don't do this I think it will have quite
a huge impact so
keep in mind in in the the gentleman
from the Retirement Systems who's who's
here can talk about the rate drop that's
that's occurring
in the next two years the success of the
Investments have made it so that the
employer rate is going down in the next
um the next two-year cycle
six percent
use your mic representative are you
telling me the concentration rate for
employers is going on no no the return
on the investment
I'm talking about the rates the employer
rates are going down well you talked
about improving situation and I'm saying
it's minus seven percent
sure that that's a substantial drop in
the employer rate
for and that's locked in for two years
so we're not even asking for the
employers to absorb that as part of you
know say okay you're dropping seven
we're asking for 2.6
to meet in the middle we're saying take
the seven percent drop in employer rates
enjoy it and fund this
out of the state coffers to not increase
any sort of overall debt to the unfunded
liability what is the employer rate for
a fireman at this exact moment 20
something help me out with that I don't
have it off top my head
that's yeah that's not it
if the gentleman from the retirement
system could come to the table no that
you have that off the top of your head I
don't have the exact number but it's
around 29 the employers 29 Points
something you know it's not that high
it's not that high you're sure yeah I'm
sure 23.
23 23. okay my phone so that's going to
drop
one of it one at a time please yeah that
went down the last two years as well I
but the point the point of overall point
is that it's it is going down because as
the as the plan that was put into place
has been going on for the last 11 years
to reduce and eliminate the unfunded
liability as successes occur in that the
employer rate is adjusted
for that based on a termination of a
2039 date the employees pay the same no
matter what whether the success or or
pitfalls that that's locked in in
statute
do you see those folks that this would
affect staying on longer did I hear you
say that earlier well the carrot has
been dangled and that's the point here
is we're we're demanding a year minimum
they have no choice they would have to
give an additional year and by we're
talking about a substantial morale
change for those groups of folks and now
it is more advantageous for them to stay
it's worth more for them to stay and
that is the goal ultimately is to get
these folks to work as long as they can
because the longer they work the better
it is for the system
for other questions from the division
and I'll representative Weiler is there
anywhere in the present budget that this
25 million is listed
I don't believe so no sir so this would
be new money
when we already have a 90 million dollar
hole
the gentleman from the retirement system
representative McGuire has a question
for you
yes so
um can you go in more detail about the
fiscal note where where does this 13
million 860
000 on the political subdivisions come
from
that is um that that part is the
increase in uh
in the the rates in fiscal 2026 that's
attributable to
a slight bit of underfunding because
the present value of the 250 million
over 10 years is only 187 million and
that's fully applicable to the group too
and so this is attributable to increases
relating to the cost of the increase in
the maximum benefit for the group ones
so this is a one-time no this is this
would be an increase in rates ongoing
so the employer the municipal employers
will pay an extra 2.6 2.7 percent right
um
yeah in perpetuity
I see no let's thank you and if I could
just clarify the reason I was high on
the rates before is I was including the
medical subsidy portion in my head not
any further follow-up from anyone on the
division
and Mr chairman that that 2.6 and 2.7 is
if this entire thing was dumped onto the
municipalities and the state paid
nothing that is it's not happening
simultaneously where the request for
Appropriations
and the rate increase are together
that's an either or so if this to follow
up on representative McGuire's questions
so if the state did not provide the 25
million dollar appropriation
what would be the impact on
municipalities what would the percentage
rate be repeat the first part of that
one more time so if the state didn't
provide the 25 million each year what
would be the percentage increase 2.62
for police 2.72 for fire they're shaking
their head behind you so
yeah
we didn't calculate that I believe
that's on the bottom of the third page
it says if the appropriation is not paid
employer contribution rates for police
and fire would increase by 5.58 percent
and 4.4 5.41 percent
that's it and the Actuarial accrued
liability would increase by 203 million
right so that's if the state did not
contribute but the benefits correct and
the effect on the contributions when I
say in perpetuity it's until the
underfunding is gone
so okay
once again the funding's gone you're
just paying normal cost
so 2040 or whatever yeah correct if
we're on target yeah
um
but the 2.6 2.7 is because the 25
million the general fund is putting in
per year is a little too small
is that right mitigating a little of
this increase to normal costs
that are involved so it doesn't match
out exactly the same could you calculate
what that 25 million should be in order
not to put the 2.6 Etc on the
municipalities
um it's difficult to do a la carte
calculations we need we need a new bill
that says
275. well I mean 27.5 or 30 million a
year and then we could have our
actuaries I see so we need a bill to act
on
for two reasons just to have certainty
to have the whole picture because
everything interacts and we can't build
a legislature unless we have a bill we
have to pay for the actuary ourselves
that's a little selfish there thank you
that doesn't make sense
further questions from the division it's
250 million dollars
seeing nothing
right but still how does 33 million
dollars turn into two points you have
you have something to add or no I don't
it's kind of our motto here's less is
all right
the division has several options here we
can retain it uh we can pass it whatever
it's up to the division representative
thank you yeah I think there's a lot to
absorb here and I move to retain the
bill
second
emotions been made and seconded to
retain the bill is there further
discussion
yes representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman I so
I think the reality of this bill first I
want to commend the sponsors and
stakeholders that put this together
because it is even with all those Roman
numerals it is a substantial uh bit of
policy and financial changes that we're
making are proposed to be made to our
retirement system uh for those
individuals that join the system between
2001 and 2011.
um I think the based on the House vote
that took place a week and a half ago
um it's a the figure for FY 25 of 25
million is something we should keep in
the budget and find room for in the
budget because it's the house position
on the policy uh and I don't think we
should go to the floor with a budget
that we don't think the house will like
every portion of it
um
I would support retaining I would also
support uh avert of of strategy of
passing the bill as well giving it a
separate vote for an appropriation on
the house floor along with making sure
that we incorporate into the budget just
to make sure that we're making sure that
the policy and the pages of legislation
that been prepared are preserved the
right way as presented but I will be
seeing now when the clerk is ready
okay
um motion to retain representative
Maguire
aye
representative Griffin aye
representative Sweeney
aye representative cambrells hi
representative Hewitt
aye
pork boats I representative Weiler
yes
unanimous
okay so it's clear to everyone in
attendance that means as you probably
already figured out we will retain this
bill as a division there have been some
questions raised uh we'll be reaching
out to the retirement system to get some
of those questions answered
and at that we'll let you know when we